Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur 57. Ausgabe unserer kleinen Gesprächsreihe. Und heute hat mich der Weg mal wieder nach Darmstadt geführt, ins ESOC, in das Raumfahrtkontrollzentrum hier. Und dem geneigten Hörer mag der Verdacht schon aufgestiegen sein, dass wir hier wieder mal eine Mission beleuchten wollen. Und das natürlich mit der speziellen ESA-Brille. Und die Mission, um die es geht, ist Gaia. Und ja, dafür begrüße ich Florian. Florian Renck, hallo.
Hallo. Ich bin Missionsanalyst hier am Europäischen Raumfahrtkontrollzentrum und habe mit meinem Kollegen Markus Landgraf, der auch schon in der Sendung war, mehrere Male die Missionsanalyse für Gaia gemacht. Und ich freue mich jetzt auch wahnsinnig, dass der Start von Gaia relativ bald kommt. Denn das wird dann schon, ich glaube, jetzt muss ich rechnen, ich glaube es sind 23 Tage bis zum 19. Dezember, kurz vor Weihnachten.
Also die Spannung liegt hier so ein bisschen in der Luft. Bevor wir auf Gaia kommen, würde mich erst mal so ein bisschen deinen persönlichen Werdegang interessieren. Bist ja auch noch relativ jung dabei hier in dem ganzen Betrieb. Wir hatten ja auch schon so diverse alte Hasen, die von allerlei Historien zu berichten wussten. Was hat dich denn hier hergeführt? Also ich meine, Mondlandung dürfte es ja wahrscheinlich verpasst haben. Bei so vielen Leuten, die hier Mondlandung gesehen haben, zack, alles umgekippt im Kopf und so. Es musste einfach nur noch das Weltall sein.
Nein, die habe ich verpasst. Das ist vollkommen richtig. Aber ich hatte durchaus Lego-Raumschiffe in meinem Kinderzimmer stehen und habe auch seitdem wahnsinnig gerne Science-Fiction-Filme angeschaut und habe mich eigentlich immer für Raumfahrt interessiert schon. Ich habe dann in Stuttgart auch angefangen, Luft- und Raumfahrttechnik zu studieren, habe auch schon während meiner Bundeswehrzeit dann an Flugzeugen gearbeitet. Deswegen Luft- und Raumfahrttechnik, also auch die Luftfahrt hat mich eigentlich sehr interessiert. In Stuttgart habe ich mich an der Uni dann auch gleich auf Raumfahrttechnik vertieft, Regelungstechnik. Hab dann später in Sydney im Bereich Raumfahrt weiter studiert und habe dann, weil ich so begeistert davon war, auch meine Doktorarbeit im Raumfahrtbereich angefertigt. Das war dann im Bereich, ja, Librationspunkt, Missionsanalyse, was Librationspunkte sind, beziehungsweise Lagrange-Punkte werden sie auch noch genannt. Ich glaube, da reden wir dann später während der Mission nochmal drüber. Ja, und in dem Bereich kam ich dann auch eigentlich ganz früh mit der ESA, beziehungsweise auch mit dem ESOG hier direkt in Darmstein in Kontakt und hab dann auch schon fast die Hälfte meiner Doktorarbeit bei ESOG verbracht und hab hier dann als Jungwissenschaftler angefangen, nachdem ich die Doktorarbeit beendet hatte.
Ist das so gängige Praxis, dass so viele hier so ihre Doktorarbeiten dann auch schon schreiben noch mit?
Eigentlich nicht. Also das ist auch relativ unbekannt gewesen, dass diese Möglichkeit existiert. Das nennt sich NPI, Network Partnering Initiative. Und ist eigentlich eine super Sache. Da teilen sich die Uni und die ESOG dann die Kosten, wenn das sozusagen eine interessante Sache für die ESOG ist, was bei meinem Thema zum Glück der Fall war. Und wir haben jetzt, glaub ich, beim ESOG, also mir ist einer bekannt, der das jetzt auch gerade wieder macht, seine Doktorarbeit zusammen mit der ESOG. Und da profitieren natürlich beide Seiten super davon.
Aber wenn man jetzt so Raumfahrt begeistert ist, dann will man doch eigentlich erst mal Astronaut werden, oder?
Ja, das ist eine total lustige Geschichte. Ich hatte nie wirklich so den Bedarf, Astronaut zu werden. Also mich haben eigentlich schon diese Maschinen absolut fasziniert. Also wenn man so eine Rakete sieht, wie die abhebt, ich sag mal, da hab ich einfach ein riesiges Grinsen im Gesicht.
Das erste Mal gesehen.
Gott, das ist jetzt echt eine gute Frage.
Warst du mal live dabei schon mal?
Ja, ich war einmal live dabei. Ich hab ein Riesenglück gehabt, in Cape Canaveral einen Shuttle-Start zu sehen.
Und?
Ja, ein ganz klasse Gefühl, sag ich mal. Das ist auch...
Die meisten dürften es noch nicht miterlebt haben.
Ja, es war ein Nachtstart, muss man sagen. Und der erste Starttermin, also es waren mehrere, natürlich hat es beim ersten Mal nicht geklappt. Und es war natürlich Riesenspannung, sag ich mal, vorhanden. Wir standen auf dem Balkon und haben die beiden Launchpads gesehen. Also in Cape Canaveral gibt es zwei, von denen das Shuttle gestartet ist, muss man ja leider sagen. Es fliegt ja nicht mehr. Und es war ein Start um Mitternacht rum. Und es war natürlich Florida im Sommer. Es war natürlich Gewitter unterwegs. Und die Gewitter müssen natürlich einen entsprechenden Abstand vom Launchpad haben. Und jeder stand da und hat geschaut, blitzt es noch, wo blitzt es, in welche Richtung sind die Blitze. Und ich habe auch ganz tolle Fotos, wo das Shuttle sozusagen auf dem Startpad steht und ein Blitz im Hintergrund gerade einschlägt. Leider ist es in der Nacht dann nicht gestartet. Umso spannender war es dann natürlich am nächsten Abend. Ja, wird es passieren, man ist da wieder hingefahren und man sieht dann dieses toll erleuchtete Shuttle nachts.
Aus welchem Abstand?
Beim zweiten Mal war ich zu spät, muss ich sagen. Beim ersten Mal durfte ich noch auf das NASA-Gelände. Beim zweiten Mal war ich da ein bisschen weiter weg, weil ich einfach zu spät da war. Wir sind nicht mal durchs Tor gekommen, weil wir am Stau standen.
Also gar nicht auf der Halbinsel, sondern gegenüber.
Ja, aber es war trotzdem noch ein paar Kilometer Abstand. Aber man sieht es doch sehr deutlich, es ist ja schön angestrahlt. Und man kriegt dann natürlich auch im Radio den Countdown mit, bzw. alle anderen Leute um einen herum zählen auch mit. Und man weiß ja gar nicht, wird es wirklich starten, so wie das wirklich passieren wird. Und es ist dann absolut gigantisch. Man sieht dann diesen hellen Lichtblitz und man kann sich das gar nicht vorstellen, was von der Energie sich da entlädt. Weil die Nacht wird wirklich zum Tag, wenn der Shuttle startet. Also die Abgase von der Rakete sind so hell, es ist wirklich alles hell erleuchtet. Und dann hebt es eben den Himmel ab, man hört dieses richtig dumme Grollen. Und dann merkt man, was für eine Energie da wirklich am Werk ist, um etwas in den Weltraum zu bewegen. Und ich fand es ganz faszinierend, weil das war dann auch vom Wetter her total traumhaft, dass eine relativ niedrige Wolkenschicht da war, so eine leichte. Ich weiß noch genau den Moment, wo das Shuttle dann sozusagen durch diese Wolkenschicht durchgestoßen ist, wie sich dann auf einmal alles verändert hat. Man hat die Wolkenschicht von oben beleuchtet gesehen, die nächste, weil das reflektiert hat. Einfach ein total geniales Spektakel, sag ich mal. Also wenn man es miterleben kann, ich glaube, jeder wird das irgendwie ließen.
Leider ist ja Kuro nicht so um die Ecke.
Manche Starts sieht man auch nicht, wie jetzt den Swarmstart, der ja im Nebel stattfand. Da hatte man zwei Sekunden Spaß, dann war alles wieder dunkel.
Richtig. An der Stelle sei noch kurz verwiesen auf die 19. Ausgabe von Raumzeit, wo wir uns intensiv mit dem Space Shuttle und seiner Geschichte beschäftigt haben, auch inklusive einer schönen Startschilderung. Das scheint durchaus verbreitet zu sein, dass das so tiefe Spuren hinterlässt. Okay, also Astronaut wolltest du nicht werden, aber du wolltest irgendwie was mit den Maschinen zu tun haben. Hätte man ja auch immer noch, hab ich bauen können.
Hab ich auch. Muss ich sagen, während dem Studium auch ein ESA-Projekt, das war sozusagen mein erster Kontakt. SETI ist aber eine andere Abkürzung als die Suche nach Außerirdischen, das ist mit Doppel S geschrieben, ist Student Space Exploration and Technology Initiative. Und während dem Studium gab es dann sozusagen für verschiedenste Universitäten aus ganz Europa, an einem Satellitenprojekt mitzuarbeiten. Und da war die Uni Stuttgart daran beteiligt. Und wir haben dann in Stuttgart für diesen Satelliten das Antriebssystem gebaut. Also der Satellit hieß dann SETI Express. Gibt es jetzt auch noch zwei Nachfolger, also ESEO, European Student Earth Orbiter und European Student Moon Orbiter, an denen gearbeitet wird. Und da habe ich dann als Student tatsächlich an einem kleinen Satelliten mitbauen können. Er hat zwar nicht lange funktioniert, muss ich leider sagen, aber er hat es in Orbit geschafft. Wir haben Funksignale gehabt.
Also typischen Test-Satelliten, die so als Beilage dann noch bei irgendwelchen Missionen, wenn noch ein paar Kilo über sind, dann noch dazu gesteckt werden.
Genau, das ist dann, was man ein Piggyback nennt beim Start. Wenn einfach ein Hauptsatellit nicht die ganze Nutzlastkapazität von einer Rakete ausnutzt, dann dürfen eben noch kleinere Studentensatelliten mitfliegen und werden dann einfach mit nach oben genommen.
Das ist dann wahrscheinlich auch noch mal ein ganz besonderer Kick, wenn man auf einmal so an irgendwas mitgeschraubt hat und das funkt einen dann so aus dem All an?
Ja, also natürlich noch besonderer, weil man ja nur Student war sozusagen und man ist dann schon wahnsinnig stolz, wenn man weiß, das Ding ist jetzt da oben und dann kommt die Information, ja es kam Datenpaket von dem Ding an und es ist einfach ein ganz toller Moment, sag ich mal, den man im Leben auch nicht vergisst, weil es ist ja letztendlich der erste Erfolg der Karriere, muss man auch so ein bisschen sagen.
Ja, aber das Interessante, du sprichst ja über die zahlreiche Projektnamen an, hier wo die ESA mit den Universitäten zusammenarbeitet, die ich glaube ich auch hier bei Raumzeit so noch nicht benannt hatten. Also wir hatten ja auch schon mal die entsprechenden Rexus-Spexus-Aktivitäten zum Beispiel vom DLR hier auch beleuchtet, was ja auch so ähnliches langfristiges Projekt ist, wo man da ja mitbauen kann. Ballon-Experimente, Raketenexperimente halt im Kleinen. Raumzeit 45 war das übrigens. Aber das ist ja auch sehr weitreichend hier mit den SETI. Ist das nur mit der Uni Stuttgart?
Nein, das sind Universitäten über ganz Europa verteilt. Also wirklich alle ESA-Mitgliedstaaten können da mitmachen bzw. bei SETI waren dann tatsächlich auch schon Universitäten von Nicht-Mitgliedstaaten mit dabei, die sind aber inzwischen Mitgliedsstaaten geworden. Associated Members haben wir ja auch. Und das dient natürlich, also was heißt dient dazu, bereitet natürlich auch auf die Raumfahrt vor. Die Raumfahrt ist ja in keinem Land angesiedelt. Also das kann ein einzelnes Land gar nicht stemmen und deswegen gibt es ja die ESA sozusagen. Und das ist einfach ein total internationales Umfeld. Vom Arbeiten her, man lernt diese ganzen, ja, Werkzeuge kennen. Wie können wir denn über die Grenzen hinweg zusammenarbeiten? Wie kriegen wir so ein Projekt gestemmt? Und natürlich auch ist super. Ich meine, unsere Muttersprache ist jetzt nicht gerade Englisch. Und man lernt das dann natürlich auch. Es ist klasse. Also es ist eine klasse Sache.
Auch diese übergreifende, länderübergreifende Kommunikation. Diese ganze internationale. Das ist ja auch was hier häufig in Gesprächen immer wieder rauskommt, gerade wenn man sich mit Astronauten unterhält, wie selbstverständlich für die so diese internationale Kooperation ist. So, also so dieses Selbstverständlich ist man nahezu mit jedem größeren Land, was halbwegs technisch orientiert ist, dauerhaft in Kontakt. Und das führt auch zu so einer interessanten globalen Normalität, die von hier immer so aus dampft. Das ist so meine Wahrnehmung.
Bei Astronauten ist das ja noch ein bisschen extremer.
Es ist da extremer, weil ich merke das halt auch genauso gut. Ich meine, gab ja hier neulich dann auch wieder so den Fall, als die russische Mission zum Mars mal wieder drohte zu scheitern und dann ja auch letztlich gescheitert ist. Wie dann aber irgendwie so around the globe sich alle da reinhängen und irgendwie versuchen, dieses Ding zu orten und so. Darin drückt sich das ja auch aus.
Ich meine, das gemeinsame Element ist sicherlich die Faszination. Ich meine, es ist doch vollkommen egal, wer zum Mars fliegt. Ich sag mal, hauptsächlich wir fliegen zum Mars. Ob da jetzt ne russische Flagge drauf ist, unsere europäischen Sternchen oder die amerikanischen Sternchen. Hauptsache wir kommen dahin.
So, jetzt bist du also relativ früh im ESOC angedockt, aber jetzt bist du auch seit ein paar Jahren hier fest im Team. Und zwar als Missionsanalyst.
Genau, als Missionsanalyst. Und eben hauptsächlich für diese Liberationspunkt- beziehungsweise Lagrange-Punkt-Missionen. Und dann habe ich noch ein paar Exoten, auf denen ich arbeite. Und Gaia ist jetzt sozusagen die, die am weitesten fortgeschritten ist. Wie gesagt, mit ein paar Wochen noch bis zum Start. Ich habe dann eine weitere Liberationspunkt-Mission, die auch schon eine wirkliche Mission ist und keine Studie mehr. Das ist Euclid. Ist auch eine wahnsinnig interessante wissenschaftliche Geschichte. Ist eine dunkle Energie, dunkle Materie-Mission. Also ESAs Dark Matter-Mission. Und dann arbeite ich eben noch an weiteren Projekten, die noch in der Studienphase sind, wo man eben noch beschließen muss, ob das technisch überhaupt machbar ist.
Kommen wir mal auf die eigentliche Gaia-Mission oder vielleicht starten wir mal so ein bisschen mit dieser Kategorie. Also Gaia ist eine Mission, die jetzt starten soll. Das haben wir ja alles schon erwähnt. Und es geht darum, im Wesentlichen Sternbeobachtungen zu betreiben. Kann man das so zusammenfassen?
Gar nicht so Beobachtung, sondern wir müssen erst mal feststellen, was da ist. Es ist eine Volkszählung. Es ist eine galaktische Volkszählung. Gaia. Und zwar, ja, vielleicht gehen wir ein bisschen in die Historie. Es gab in den 80ern eine Mission namens Hipparcos. Und die ist natürlich nach einem Griechen benannt. Und Hipparcos war der Erste, der Astronometrie betrieben hat. Also er hat versucht, die Sterne am Himmel zu katalogisieren. Das heißt zu sagen, okay, da ist der Stern an der und der Position. Mit der Helligkeit. Und muss ich jetzt sagen, vielleicht hat er sogar auch schon die Farbe dazu geschrieben. Denn die Sterne sind ja nicht alle weiß. Man sieht sie auch mit dem bloßen Auge, dass sie manchmal durchaus einen bläulichen Schimmer haben oder einen rötlichen Schimmer. Und das hat dann Hipparcos, also die ESA-Mission Hipparcos, dann natürlich etwas viel genauer gemacht. Das heißt, was man gemacht hat, ist, man hat versucht, die Sterne in der Umgebung von unserem Sonnensystem zu vermessen, also was da ist. Das heißt, vermessen heißt, wo sind sie an der Himmelssphäre und wie weit sind sie weg? Weil was wir sehen am Himmelszelt, ist ja eigentlich nur, wo der Stern ist. Sag ich mal in Koordinaten. Sag ich mal 10 Grad Azimut und 10 Grad Elevation zu einer bestimmten Uhrzeit, da ist der Stern. Aber wie weit er weg ist, das wissen wir ja gar nicht. Und das hat man eben auch versucht herauszubekommen.
Da hängt ja auch dran, wie groß ist er eigentlich?
Ja, genau. Man sieht es ja von unterschiedlicher Helligkeit, aber die Helligkeit sagt ja noch nicht, wie weit er weg ist. Ist er groß oder ist er nah? Genau, das ist das. Und das war sozusagen zum ersten Mal, dass man versucht hat, sich die Umgebung von unserem Sonnensystem anzuschauen. Was ist denn da überhaupt? Und das war Hipparcos. Es gibt eben diesen berühmten Hipparcos-Sternen-Katalog. Es gibt dann noch einen ungenaueren. Man hat versucht, das so genau wie möglich zu machen mit Hipparcos. Und es gibt dann den Tycho-Katalog, der ist dann ein bisschen ungenauer. Also da ist dann ungefähr eine Million Sterne kartografiert. Während die genauen von Hipparcos sind, glaube ich, 140.000.
Finde ich erstaunlich. Hipparcos ist August 89 gestartet. Das ist ja jetzt dafür, dass man zu dem Zeitpunkt eigentlich schon mal so 20 Jahre lang Raumfahrt betrieben hat, mehr oder weniger aktiv. Interessant, dass man eigentlich dann erst anfängt, das mal genau auszumessen.
Ja, aber es dauert eben auch, bis die ganze Technologie bereit ist, sag ich mal. Also so eine Mission hat ja auch einen wahnsinnig langen Vorlauf. Und es ist ja auch nicht einfach, diese Instrumente zu entwickeln. Und man hat zwar vielleicht lange Raumfahrt betrieben, und die Ideen waren sicherlich schon sehr lange da. Aber man braucht eben fast auch gut 15 Jahre, heutzutage von der ersten Idee bis dann zu der Umsetzung. Also ich denke, wir werden nachher durchaus drüber reden, wie kompliziert das eigentlich ist, so ein Instrument zu bauen und was da alles beachtet werden muss. Also diese Genauigkeiten, die man da versucht zu erreichen. Und das ist natürlich etwas, man arbeitet an der absoluten Grenze des technisch Machbaren. Und deswegen dauert das eben manchmal auch etwas länger als gedacht. Also ich meine, Raumfahrtmissionen haben ja so den Trend, dass sie zu spät starten. Aber das muss man auch ein bisschen dadurch verstehen, dass man versucht, die Technologie bis zum Ende auszureizen. Und manchmal, man kennt die Technologie ja am Anfang unter Umständen noch gar nicht. Und man verschätzt sich eben ein bisschen, wie lange es dauert, um etwas in den Griff zu bekommen. Dafür bekommt man aber natürlich auch Wissenschaftsdaten zurück, die absolut brillant sind und eben an der Grenze von dem, was wir technisch machen können, liegen.
Ja und nicht zu vergessen, jeder Satellit ist ein Prototyp. Das sind immer so die ersten davon, die jemals davon gebaut wurden. Und wenn man es zehn Jahre später nochmal macht, baut man ja nicht das gleiche normal, sondern man nutzt den technologischen Fortschritt, um halt wieder bis an die Grenze zu gehen. Aber man muss im Rahmen des Bauens ja überhaupt erstmal schauen, wo ist denn eigentlich die Grenze?
Vollkommen richtig. Und letztendlich macht Gaia ja nichts anderes, als Hipparcos machen sollte. Nur muss man sich das vor Augen führen. Man sagt, Hipparcos, grobgesprochen 100.000 Sterne, die vermessen würden, gehen wir mit Gaia viel, viel weiter. Wir werden über eine Milliarde Sterne vermessen. Und jetzt muss man sich die Größenordnung wieder vorstellen. Eine Milliarde, es hört sich viel an.
Das ist ja eigentlich nicht so viel. Das ist ja gerade mal so ein Prozent unserer Galaxie.
Wollte ich gerade drauf eingehen. Eine Milliarde, es hört sich erstmal viel an, ist aber gar nicht viel. Wir werden die Population von ungefähr einem Prozent unserer Galaxien, unserer Galaxie kennen. Und man muss sich dann vor Augen halten, dass es davon Milliarden Galaxien gibt.
Was ist denn da jetzt die Begrenzung? Also ich meine, warum guckt man sich die gleich alle an?
Na das liegt natürlich in der Technologie. An der Technologie, die wir heute haben. Hoffentlich werden wir irgendwann in der Lage sein, noch weiterzugehen. Aber das ist natürlich extrem schwer.
Das ist jetzt auch nur eine Schätzung. Also man geht jetzt mal davon aus, dass man so viele damit sehen können wird.
Ja, das ist natürlich eine Schätzung. Man hofft natürlich mehr. Man weiß ja gar nicht, wie viele Sterne in unserer Galaxie existieren. Man sagt ja immer, es sind ungefähr 100 Milliarden ungefähr. Beziehungsweise habe ich dann auch lustigerweise auf dem Gaia-Blog gelesen, dass dann jemand geschrieben hat, ja vielleicht sind es 200 Milliarden. Und plus minus 100 Milliarden. So ganz grob gesprochen. Und das ist ja das Spannende. Wir müssen ja erstmal herausfinden, was denn da überhaupt in unserer Umgebung alles vorhanden ist. Und das ist natürlich technologisch wahnsinnig schwer. Und jetzt kommt natürlich die Frage, warum macht man nicht alle? Man muss sich vorstellen, wir schauen uns Sterne an, die sind natürlich sehr nah dran und sind sehr hell. Und dann schauen wir uns Sterne an, die sind sehr weit weg und sehr dunkel. Und dadurch, dass sie sehr weit weg sind, kommen sie uns ja noch viel dunkler vor. Und der Sensor, der jetzt bei Gaia verbaut ist, muss das natürlich beherrschen. Der muss wahnsinnig dunkle Punkte eigentlich vor diesem Hintergrund, wo ein paar hundert Photonen auf diesen Sensor fallen, vermessen und sagen, hey, ich hab da einen Stern gesehen. Und dann muss er aber auch etwas sehen, was sozusagen auf jeder CCD-Kamera, wenn man ein Foto davon machen will, eigentlich den Chip überstrahlt. Und das ist natürlich eine riesen Reichweite. Und die Sensitivität von diesem Gaia-Sensor muss man sich überlegen. Man sieht, wenn man Sternen mit dem Auge sehen kann, gerade noch am Himmel, ist Gaia 400.000 Mal feiner, was Gaia noch detektieren kann. Und deswegen kriegt man dann eben diese eine Milliarde Sterne. Aber irgendwann sind die Sterne dann eben auch so weit weg, dass wir sie einfach mit Gaia auch dann nicht mehr detektieren können. Aber wer weiß, in 20 Jahren haben wir vielleicht noch bessere Sensoren. Und dann kriegen wir vielleicht 100 Milliarden Sterne hin.
Letztlich müsste ja aber auch nicht nur jetzt die eigene Galaxie dabei abfallen, sondern auch sehr wohl andere Galaxien.
Ja, aber das ist...
Oder geht es primär um die Milchstraße?
Es geht primär um die Milchstraße. Also es geht wirklich um das, was wir jetzt sehen. Weil Gaia ist keine typische Mission, die jetzt einen Sensor hat und sozusagen eine Fotografie macht. Das muss man sagen. Eigentlich dreht Gaia ein Video. Und zwar ein unendlich langes Video, ein 5-Jahres-Video von unserer Galaxis. Denn Gaia, wenn es die Beobachtungen macht, dreht sich ganz langsam. Also das ist kein Satellit wie zum Beispiel Herschel. Ich glaube, gab es auch bei Raumzeit Herschel-Planck. Herschel schaut sich ja einfach ein Bild an und macht ein Bild. Und das wird dann runtergeladen. Während Gaia dreht sich in 24 Stunden viermal um sich selber. Also Rotationsperiode sechs Stunden. Und macht dabei sozusagen die ganze Zeit ein Video vom Himmel. Beziehungsweise zwei Videos. Weil das sind zwei Kameras, die mit einem relativ großen Winkel um einander sind.
Also um dann 360° Abdeckung auch zu haben. Also überall hin.
Ja, genau. Dadurch dreht sich's. Wir haben diese Kameras. Und über das Jahr hin, dadurch, dass Gaia sozusagen mit der Erde dann um die Sonne wandert, kriegen wir dann den gesamten Himmel abgedeckt. Und zwar ist die Mission, also die nominelle Missionsdauer von Gaia ist fünf Jahre. Und während fünf Jahre sollte jeder Stern, den wir dediktieren, ungefähr 70-mal abgescannt worden sein. Und dann braucht das, also man muss das relativ häufig machen, weil sich die Sterne ja auch bewegen. Und man will genau, also man will nicht nur wissen, wo der Stern ist am Himmel, sondern man will auch wissen, wo er sich hin bewegt. Und deswegen macht man sozusagen diese wiederholte Beobachtung von den Sternen.
Und das ist ein Abfallprodukt, wenn man sich auch selber also zwangsläufig dabei bewegt, weil man mit der Erde mitmarschiert und mit dem Sonnensystem mitmarschiert und so innerhalb der Galaxis. Ich weiß, die Bewegung ist wahrscheinlich nicht so relevant, aber all diese Bewegung führt ja dann dazu, dass man dann die Sterne nicht nur 70 mal sieht, sondern auch aus 70 verschiedenen Perspektiven und anderen Konstellationen sieht.
Ja, also den Stern selber sieht man natürlich eigentlich immer nur von einer Seite. Aber was wichtig ist und was sehr wichtig ist für die Messung, ist genau, dass sich die Konstellation tatsächlich verändert. Und zwar messen wir ja, sag ich mal, wir sehen den gleichen Stern im Frühjahr und im Sommer. Der Unterschied ist, dass wir uns im Frühjahr in unserem Sonnensystem an einer anderen Position befinden wie im Sommer. Und zwar zwei astronomische Einheiten entfernt. Also die Erde ist ja sozusagen in einem halben Jahr umgelaufen. Und damit verändert sich die Position von einem Stern in der Nähe der Erde ganz leicht vor dem Hintergrund. Und da kommen nämlich die anderen Galaxien ins Spiel zum Beispiel. Die, die Sterne, die ganz weit weg sind, die verändern ihre Position zu uns fast gar nicht. Die sind wirklich fix. Aber Sterne, die nahe dran sind, die sehen wir aus unterschiedlichen Positionen. Und die verändern ihre Position vor dem Sternenhintergrund ganz leicht. Und das ist diese, man nennt das Parallaxe. Und das ist genau der Effekt, wie wir feststellen können, wie weit ein Stern weg ist. Wir messen diesen Winkelfehler, oder es ist kein Fehler, also einfach diese Winkelabweichung ganz haargenau. Und das ist einer der riesen Vorteile von Gaia, was wir können. Und dann können wir aus diesem Winkel zurückrechnen, wie weit der Stern tatsächlich von uns weg ist.
Also im Prinzip derselbe Effekt, den man so hat, wenn man so das linke Auge, das rechte Auge zumacht, und dann alles, was weit weg ist, bewegt sich fast gar nicht, alles, was ganz nah dran ist, ist ein riesen Unterschied.
Genau, man kann da einen wunderschönen Test machen. Einfach den Daumen ausstrecken, sich vor die Nase halten und ein Auge zumachen und dann, sage ich mal, schauen, wo der Daumen vor dem Hintergrund sich aufhält, dann das Auge schließen, das andere Auge aufmachen und man sieht, dass der Daumen vor dem Hintergrund gewandert ist. Also der Hintergrund ist natürlich festgeblieben, der Daumen ist vor dem Hintergrund an einer anderen Position. Und man kann das jetzt noch schöner machen, man kann den Daumen natürlich nahe an die Naserand führen bzw. den Daumen sehr weit wegführen und sieht, dass je weiter er weg ist, die relative Position vor dem Hintergrund immer kleiner wird, dieser Fehler. Und jetzt muss man sich vorstellen, dass diese Sternen sehr, sehr weit weg sind. Das sind ja Lichtjahre. Und das heißt, dieser Winkel, den wir sehen, ist extrem winzig. Und man muss sich das so vorstellen, dass der Winkel, den wir messen können, kann man in so einem kleinen Beispiel bringen, wenn man auf dem Mond sein Badetuch auslegen würde und man das zweite Badetuch danebenlegt, weil man auf dem Mond einen Sonnenbad genießen will, dann könnte man von der Erde, muss man diesen Winkel so genau vermessen, dass man diese zwei Badetücher tatsächlich vom Winkel her trennen kann. Und das kann man sich vorstellen, wie weit der Mond erstmal weg ist und was wir mit dem bloßen Auge auf dem Mond sehen. Garantiert keine zwei Badehandtücher, die nebeneinander liegen. Das ist eigentlich von der Technik her, finde ich, wahnsinnig faszinierend, was da für Genauigkeiten wirklich erreicht werden mit so einem Instrument.
Wie viele Kummerstellen im Winkel müssen da dann drücksichtigt werden?
Der Vollkreis hat 360 Grad. Wenn man 1 Grad von diesen 360 unterteilt, hat man ja 60 Bogenminuten. Und dann jede Bogenminute ist wieder unterteilt in 60 Bogensekunden. Wenn man jetzt 20 Millionstel von dieser Bogensekunde nimmt, dann hat man, was Gaia bei relativ dunklen Sternen schafft und sieben Mikrobogensekunden, ähm, nee, nicht Mikro, nicht Mikro, Mikro, muss man sehr vorsichtig sein damit, ist dann der Winkelabstand, den Gaia bei hellen Objekten schafft. Da ist noch ein kleiner Unterschied zwischen hell und dunkleren Objekten. Und das ist absolut faszinierend, was so ein Instrument da erreichen muss. Und da ist natürlich zum Beispiel auch das Material vollkommen faszinierend. Also, wir haben vorhin über den Raketenstart geredet. Das ist ja was unglaublich Brutales, was sich da von Energie inlädt. Und jetzt muss man sich vorstellen, dass dieser Satellit da oben in der Rakete ja gerüttelt wird. Und das ist nicht angenehm. Also man sieht es ja vielleicht auch bei den Shuttle-Starts oder von Apollo 5, die alten Aufnahmen, gibt es ja, wie die Astronauten da drin sitzen und wirklich durchgeschüttelt werden. Und das Gleiche passiert natürlich mit dem Satelliten. Und da darf sich natürlich während dem Start absolut nichts verstellen an diesem Instrument. Sonst bringen die Messungen natürlich nicht die Qualität, die man braucht. Und das ist ein bisschen diese Faszination Raumfahrt. Das ist dann Materialtechnik, da geht es wieder.
Bleiben wir noch mal so ein bisschen bei dem Aufgabenfeld. Was schon lange da ist, was man maximal bearbeiten will und was jetzt eigentlich das zweite Mal, zumindest jetzt von der ESA, das zweite Mal gemacht wird. Gab es denn noch andere Missionen der Amerikaner oder der Russen, die ähnliches versucht haben?
Ich müsste jetzt lügen, ich sag jetzt einmal mal, meines Wissens nicht, aber ich leg nicht die Hand dafür ins Feuer.
Okay, also zumindest jetzt nichts, wovon jeder die ganze Zeit redet.
Also dieser Hipparcos-Katalog ist, rein ist wissen schon, der Bekannte, der immer erwähnt wird und auch immer zitiert wird.
Also so ein typischer europäischer Spleen, es ist wie immer ganz genau...
Ja, es ist eine gute europäische Tradition.
Also man möchte am Ende wissen, möglichst viele Sterne und vielleicht daraus auch ableiten können, wie viele es vielleicht gibt. Ich meine, das ist ja immer noch so ein Fragezeichen. Also was kann man daraus eigentlich interpolieren und hochrechnen, wie viel es wirklich gibt? Wo sind sie? Wohin bewegen sie sich? Bewegen sie sich denn eigentlich auch alle gleich schnell? Ich meine, wenn man jetzt so eine Bewegung hat, dann kann ich sagen, ja okay, vorher war er da, jetzt ist er da. Dann kann ich ja eigentlich dann den Abstand auch nur dann wirklich auch bemessen, wenn ich weiß, wie schnell er sich selbst bewegt. Sind die alle gleich schnell?
Nein, gar nicht. Also da treten natürlich vollkommen unterschiedliche Effekte auf. Erstmal von der Entstehung der Sterne, wie sie entstanden sind. Dann werden manche Sterne natürlich von Supernova beschleunigt und weggestoßen. Das gibt es natürlich alles. Also sie haben tatsächlich vollkommen unterschiedliche Geschwindigkeiten. Aber das Faszinierende daran ist, dass man, wenn man die Geschwindigkeit sehr genau vermessen hat, kann man ja sagen, wo sie hinfliegen werden und wo sie waren. Und zum Beispiel eine ganz interessante Frage ist, wir haben ja Kometen bei uns im Sonnensystem. Und die Theorie ist, dass andere Sterne sozusagen an der Ortschen Wolke, die unser Sonnensystem sehr, sehr weit außen umgibt, vorbeigeflogen sind. Und dadurch, also manche Trümmerteile letztendlich abgelenkt haben und dafür gesorgt haben, dass die ins Innere unseres Sonnensystems fallen. Und das ist natürlich ganz faszinierend, weil wir können jetzt schauen, welche Sterne sind denn bei uns in der Umgebung, wo bewegen die sich hin und waren die wirklich mal vielleicht in der Nähe unserer Sonne und können die diesen Effekt erzeugt haben?
Der Erkenntnis gewinnt. Meine Frage ging jetzt eher so, kriegt man das eigentlich so problemlos gelöst? Also ist das sozusagen durch diese Beobachtung über die Zeit, kann man dann irgendwann sagen, ja okay, kann jetzt sein, dass er besonders nahe ist, kann aber auch sein, dass er nur besonders schnell ist?
Nee, also das kann man dann schon auflösen.
Weil man das dann immer in Relation zu einem anderen stellt.
Ja, natürlich ist das wahnsinnig kompliziert. Auch für eine Milliarde Objekte, vielleicht mal für die man das machen will. Und kriegt man das einfach gelöst. Die Antwort ist auch sehr einfach nein. Da beschäftigen sich 450 Leute in den Science-Centern, also in den Wissenschaftszentren, die die Gaia-Daten dann auswerten nach der Mission oder bereits während der Mission, muss man ja sagen. Und das ist natürlich wahnsinnig kompliziert. Das braucht auch wahnsinnig viel Rechenleistung. Also ich hab mal die Zahl gehört, das, was am Ende bereitstehen wird an Gaia-Sternenkatalog, ist ein Petabyte an Informationen über, wo ist der Stern, wo bewegt er sich hin. Wir machen ja auch zum Beispiel Spektroskopie. Wir erfahren ja tatsächlich auch etwas über den Stern. Also Spektroskopie, wir schauen uns das Spektrum des Sterns an, das Lichtspektrum.
Und damit dann halt die Zusammensetzung, die welche Elemente in dem Stern in welchem Maße vertreten sind.
Richtig. Und das ist natürlich keine einfache Aufgabe. Und nachdem wir das natürlich sehr präzise machen wollen, müssen wir sehr, sehr viele Sachen extrem präzise kennen. Zum Beispiel, wo ist Gaia überhaupt, wenn es diese Beobachtung macht? Wo ist der Satellit? Und das muss man natürlich vom Boden aus bestimmen können, mit einer ganz, ganz hohen Präzision. Und zum Beispiel reichen unsere Standardmethoden da gar nicht aus, die wir sonst für Satelliten verwenden. Das heißt, da musste man halt andere Methoden finden, wie wir bessere Informationen bekommen können, wo der Satellit ist.
Das heißt, die Eigenpositionierung, wo sich der Satellit selbst befindet, das muss noch genauer sein, als das jetzt für zum Beispiel Planck oder Herschel erforderlich war?
Ja, genau. Weil wenn wir die Position der Planeten, das sind natürlich die Sterne, die wir vermessen, wenn wir genau sagen sollen, wo die sind, dann müssen wir das ja auf irgendetwas beziehen.
Wo man selber ist.
Und da muss man natürlich ganz genau wissen, wo man selber ist, sonst macht man natürlich auch wieder Fehler im Winkel.
Interessanter Punkt. Man muss doch sowieso eigentlich immer wissen, wo der eigene Satellit ist, weil sonst ist er ja vielleicht irgendwann mal nicht mehr da, wo man denkt, wo er ist. Also wie genau weiß man denn das normalerweise bei Satelliten? Und wie genau ist das jetzt bei Gaia erforderlich? Also wie viel, welchem Maß, da muss ja die Präzision erhöht werden und wodurch?
Also generell kann man das ja leider nicht sagen, weil das kommt natürlich vollkommen auf die Mission drauf an, die man verfolgt. Manche Satelliten haben tatsächlich keine große Anforderungen, wo sie sein müssen. Bei Herschel sind da keine riesigen Anforderungen vorhanden.
Bei Planken sagen die auch nicht. Da ging es ja eigentlich nur darum, dass man so gleichmäßig überall hinguckt.
Ja.
Aber das Rauschen kommt ja sowieso von überall.
Da sind dann mehr operationelle Aspekte dahinter. Natürlich, dass man mit dem Satelliten noch Kontakt aufnehmen können muss. Also man muss ja wissen, wo er sein wird. Aber bei eben Astrometrie-Missionen ist es eben ganz entscheidend, wo ist der Satellit mit der hohen Genauigkeit. Und da muss man über diese Entfernung, also Gaia ist ungefähr 1,5 Millionen Kilometer von der Erde weg. Und da muss man schon in den 100-Meter-Bereich gehen. Und das ist gar nicht so einfach, das so genau festzustellen.
Das Absurde ist doch eigentlich, dass normalerweise ja die Satelliten ihre eigene Position über die Sterne bestimmen.
Und das ist nicht ganz richtig. Sie können ihre Lage über die Sterne bestimmen. Du spielst da glaube ich die Sternenkameras an, die Star Trekker. Und die schauen sich die Sterne tatsächlich an, identifizieren bestimmte Konstellationen und dann können sie sagen, welche Lage der Satellit gerade hat. Also in welche Richtung er guckt. Aber wo sie sind, können sie nicht bestimmen. Das ist wirklich sehr schwer. Das wird auch vom Boden aus gemacht.
Okay, wie wird das gemacht?
Das machen wir mit Bodenstationen. Wir nutzen da verschiedene Effekte aus. Einerseits sind auf dem Satellit einen Transponder installiert. Und was wir machen, wir schicken sozusagen einen Ping hin. Und der Satellit schickt einfach dieses gleiche Signal zurück als Pong. Und wir messen die Laufzeit. Und der Transponder ist vorher ganz genau vermessen worden, was die eigene Latenz ist. Genau, vollkommen richtig. Und wir können dann einfach messen, wie lange das Signal braucht. Damit kriegen wir natürlich eine Entfernungsinformation. Und wenn man jetzt die Frequenz von dem Signal sehr genau kennt, kann man natürlich auch die Dopplerverschiebung messen. Das heißt, das ist die Frequenzverschiebung aufgrund der Radialgeschwindigkeit des Satelliten. Also wenn sich der Satellit von uns weg bewegt und das Signal schickt, dann ist die Frequenz, man sagt, ins Rote verschoben. Das heißt, die Wellen kommen... Also werden langwelliger.... werden langwelliger, während wenn sich der Satellit zum Beispiel auf uns zu bewegt, nennt man das eben die Bauverschiebung, die Wellen werden kürzer, sieht man auch im Optischen natürlich. Aber man kann den gleichen Effekt auch mit Radiowellen nutzen. Und über dieses Ranging, wie man das nennt, also diese Entfernungsmessung und diesen Doppler-Messung, kann man dann eben eine Orbitbestimmung durchführen. Das ist eine ganz interessante Sache. Und dann kommen natürlich andere Sachen dazu, wie optische Beobachtungen zum Beispiel. Man hat natürlich den Vorteil, dass Satelliten wie Gaia die ganze Zeit in der Sonne sind, also aufgrund des Missionsdesigns, wie wir das gemacht haben. Und dann kann man natürlich sie tatsächlich auch vor dem Sternenhintergrund von der Erde aus noch abfotografieren, tatsächlich mit einem Teleskop eine Aufnahme machen. Und jetzt stimmt ein bisschen das, was du vorher gesagt hast mit den Sternenkameras. Wir haben dann Gaia vor dem Sternenhintergrund und können das natürlich in den Navigationsfilter einspeisen, diese Information, und bekommen damit dann eine noch genauere Orbitbestimmung, wo Gaia ist.
Vielleicht bloß so verdreht, dass man jetzt eigentlich überhaupt erst mal alles ganz genau ausmessen will, aber trotzdem das, was man sieht, auch schon wieder mit einbezogen wird.
Und das ist was total Faszinierenderes auch an Gaia, dass Gaia im Laufe der Mission sich selber verbessern wird. Denn man wird dann irgendwann den Gaia-Sternenkatalog natürlich verwenden, um die Position von Gaia, die man vorher hatte, noch zu verbessern. Und damit ist das natürlich so eine iterative Geschichte. Also man nimmt eine Position für Gaia an, macht damit den Sternenkatalog von Gaia und bekommt damit natürlich einen genaueren Sternenkatalog. Und dann nimmt man diesen Sternenkatalog wieder, schmeißt ihn rein und hat bessere Ergebnisse von Gaias Position. Und dann kann man im Laufe der Mission das Ganze noch verbessern.
Keine Beschäftigungsarmut für Mathematiker auf jeden Fall. Es hast du gesagt, 100 Meter...
Im 100 Meter Bereich...
.müsste der Satellit quasi in der Position bestimmt werden zu jedem Zeitpunkt. Normalerweise... Ich weiß jetzt nicht, was ein gutes Beispiel wäre für eine andere Mission, die auch schon relativ hohe Positionsanforderungen hätte. Hintergrundstrahlungsbeobachtung ist es jetzt wahrscheinlich eher nicht. Was nimmt man da normalerweise so?
Man muss es unterscheiden. Man bekommt meistens doch relativ gute Positionsgenauigkeiten hin. Es gibt nur bestimmte Konstellationen, wenn der Satellit in einer bestimmten geometrischen Lage zur Bodenstation hat, dass dann sozusagen diese Navigationslösungen schlecht werden. Aber die Anforderung selber ist da natürlich nicht so hoch. Man macht das natürlich bei den Satelliten, also auch bei Planck oder Herschl, macht man natürlich trotzdem die Positionsbestimmung so genau wie möglich, weil man damit den Treibstoffverbrauch minimieren kann. Aber wie gesagt, das ist vollkommissionsabhängig, wie genau man das wirklich bestimmen muss.
Da wurde ja gesagt, es müsste jetzt mal genauer gemacht werden, als es bisher getan wurde.
Ja, also es ist natürlich schon so, dass die meiste Zeit bei diesen Liberationspunktmissionen auch diese Lagegenauigkeit erreicht wird. Aber während bestimmter Zeiten eben nicht. Und dann verschlechtert sie sich.
Bei Gaia war es sozusagen nicht entschuldbar, dass man das irgendwann mal nicht genau hat, sondern man muss einfach immer genau sein.
Richtig, genau.
Aber wie kann man denn dann diese schlechten Konstellationen dann ausgleichen?
Wie gesagt, wir machen das bei Gaia dann zum Beispiel mit Optik. Also wirklich vom Boden aus wird dann das mit dem Teleskop angeschaut. Und dann bekommt man eben eine Winkelinformation, die man bei Doppler bzw. dieser Entfernungsmessung dann erstmal nicht so genau hat. Und dann haben wir eine ganz, ganz genaue Winkelbestimmung.
Jetzt haben wir es schon mehrfach angesprochen. So eine Beobachtungsmission befindet sich üblicherweise an einem Lagrange-Punkt. Das sind dann diese Top-Locations rund um im Prinzip jeden Himmelskörper irgendwie herum und eben bei der Erde auch. Es sind, glaube ich, insgesamt fünf. Das sind also die Orte, wo sich die Anziehungskräfte so aufheben, dass man parallel zu einem Himmelskörper so mitfliegen kann, ohne sich groß anstrengen zu müssen.
Ja, man muss da ein bisschen vorsichtig sein mit der Formulierung. Sie heben sich eben genau nicht auf, sondern die Anziehungskräfte ergänzen sich. Sie heben sich nicht weg oder so.
Keiner hat einen dominanten Einfluss mehr.
Das Faszinierende ist, das ist ein bisschen kompliziert zu erklären, diese Kombination aus Zentrifugalkraft und Gravitationskraft. Aber im Prinzip ist es so, je näher ein Körper an der Sonne dran ist und dann auf einer Kreiswand ist, kreist er umso schneller. Merkur ist ja sehr nah an der Sonne. Natürlich eine sehr kurze Umlaufperiode. Die Venus ist auch eine kürzere als die Erde. Die Erde hat dann eben genau ein Jahr. Wenn man dann weiter rausgeht zum Mars, werden die Umlaufzeiten immer länger. Und das ist durch die Gravitation der Sonne bestimmt. Und wenn jetzt die Gravitation virtuell zunehmen würde, müssten die Körper sozusagen schneller um diesen Himmelskörper umlaufen, damit sie nicht in den Himmelskörper reinfallen. Also wenn die Sonne mehr Masse hätte, müsste Merkur alle ein bisschen schneller umlaufen, damit sie eben nicht reinfallen, sondern dass sie eben die nötige Zentripetalkraft haben, oder ist es in dem Fall dann Zentrifugalkraft.
Kann man auch schön immer an irgendwelchen Freizeitparks feststellen, wo dann diese komischen Spendentrichter sind, wo Kinder ihre Münzen reinfallen lassen. Wenn die halt langsamer werden, fallen sie dann halt irgendwann rein ins Schwarze Loch. Und das war's dann.
Genau. Und man kann sich das jetzt so vorstellen, man muss jetzt im Geist die Linie ziehen, von der Sonne bis zur Erde. Und dann muss man diese Linie ein bisschen weiterzeichnen, und zwar 1,5 Millionen Kilometer hinter die Erde. Und dann muss man sich anschauen, wie jetzt die Gravitationskräfte wirken. Und zwar, wenn man da jetzt einen Satelliten sozusagen virtuell auf diesen Punkt setzt, 1,5 Millionen Kilometer hinter der Erde, von der Sonne aus gesehen, dann zieht ja die Gravitationskraft der Sonne den Satelliten an. Aber er ist weiter draußen als die Erde. Er ist ja irgendwo, natürlich viel näher als die Erde, aber er ist irgendwo zwischen Erde und Mars. Also müsste er in Theorie langsamer um die Sonne umlaufen. Tut er aber nicht. Und warum tut er das nicht? Weil wenn wir uns jetzt zu dieser Gravitationskraft der Sonne noch die Gravitationskraft der Erde einzeichnen, dann sieht der Satellit sozusagen virtuell eine stärkere Sonne. Und deswegen kann er, obwohl er weiter draußen ist als die Erde, mit der gleichen Umlaufgeschwindigkeit umlaufen wie die Erde um die Sonne. Also in einem Jahr um die Sonne.
Das ist jetzt der Lagrange Punkt 2, von dem du...
Das ist jetzt der Lagrange Punkt 2, genau. Warum gehen wir zum Lagrange Punkt 2? Das ist der hinter der Erde. Man würde erst mal denken, das ist ja vielleicht auch nicht ganz geschickt, weil die Erde steht ja dann vor der Sonne. Das heißt, wir haben da kein Licht.
Aber man will ja eigentlich auch kein Licht haben.
Doch, wir wollen Licht. Wir brauchen das Licht für die Solarzellen. Wir machen auch was sehr Kompliziertes. Wir sind nicht genau in diesem Gleichgewichtspunkt, sondern wir fliegen in den Orbit um diesen Punkt. Das ist eine relativ komplizierte Figur. Eine Lisa-Ju-Figur nennt sich das, eine Lisa-Ju-Orbit. Kann man sich vielleicht mal im Internet anschauen. Schaut recht lustig aus, so ein Lisa-Ju-Orbit um einen Liberationspunkt, damit wir eben genau nicht in den Erdschatten kommen, sondern damit wir für den Satelliten die ganze Zeit eine konstante Stromversorgung über die Solarzellen haben könnten. Und warum will man jetzt zu diesem Liberationspunkt 2? Das hat den Vorteil, dass von dem Punkt aus gesehen die Sonne, die Erde und der Mond in einer Richtung stehen. Und damit sozusagen fast die andere Himmishälfte komplett ungestört ist von Sonne, Erde und Mond. Weil das sind ja sozusagen, wenn wir andere Sterne sehen wollen, Störkörper. Und ein weiterer Vorteil ist, dass wir extrem konstante Bedingungen dort haben an diesem Liberationspunkt 2. Wie gesagt, wenn wir in diesen Lysajus-Orbit gehen, dann haben wir eine konstante Beleuchtung von dem Satelliten. Das heißt, er ist auch konstant warm. Er bekommt von der Sonne immer die gleiche Energie-Einstrahlung. Das heißt, es stört ihn nicht. Wenn wir in Erdorbit gehen, dann haben wir erstens die Strahlung von der Erde, die Albedo-Strahlung. Die Erde selber ist ja warm. Wir haben Infrarot-Strahlung. Wir haben Reflektion von der Erde. Wenn wir in den Orbit, ja es gibt sonnensynchrone Orbits, aber wenn wir zum Beispiel in den Liebligen Erdorbit sind, könnten wir in Schatten von der Erde gehen. Das sind alles Dinge, die Observatorien nicht mögen. Weil wenn wir zum Beispiel in Erdschatten gehen, ziehen sich Materialien unter Umständen zusammen, der Satellit fängt an zu vibrieren. Und das ist natürlich alles für Präzisionsbeobachtung. Wir haben ja vorhin über die Winkel gesprochen, die da erreicht werden müssen. Natürlich alles nicht gewünscht.
Das soll einfach so wenig atmen, wie es irgendwie geht.
Genau, wir wollen möglichst konstante Bedingungen. Und die haben wir natürlich an diesem Librationspunkt vorhanden. Ein weiterer Vorteil ist, dass natürlich der, wir haben um die Erde ja die Strahlungsgürtel, das heißt, wir sind in einem relativ gutmütigen, wir haben relativ gutmütige Umgebungsbedingungen, was die Strahlung angeht. Die kosmische Strahlung ist zwar vorhanden, aber wir sind nicht in diesen Van Allen Belt zum Beispiel von der Erde. Also wir sind auch weit weg und haben da auch keine Probleme. Und wie gesagt, der Mond ist natürlich auch in der gleichen Richtung. Wenn wir jetzt ein Observatorium um die Erde haben, stört uns natürlich der Mond auch ab und zu.
Durch seine Gravitation jetzt?
Nee, einfach, dass er da ist. Der würde ja dann durchs Bild laufen, würde den Sensor blenden und das will man natürlich nicht. Und so ist man dann schön, diese 1,5 Millionen Kilometer weit weg. Kann da ungestört beobachten. 1,5 Millionen Kilometer ist super, weil dann kriegt man auch noch... Also das Problem ist ja, je weiter man weggeht, desto schwieriger wird es ja auch mit den Satelliten zu kommunizieren. Das größere müssen ja die Schüssel sein, die wir hier am Boden haben. Aber mit 1,5 Millionen Kilometern ist das noch gut machbar, kriegt man auch noch ganz anständige Datenraten hin.
Das ist ja jetzt auch ein bewährtes Modell. Also wir haben ja Herschel und Planck schon ein paar Mal erwähnt, aber das waren ja jetzt gerade die beiden Missionen, die jetzt beide zu Ende gegangen sind, die im Prinzip dieselbe Örtlichkeit aufgerufen haben. Also um diesen L2 herum meandert haben, eben genau mit dieser Lissajous-Technik. Das ist, sagen wir mal, auch hier bei ESA ein beherrschtes Problem.
Ja, wobei da immer noch Unterschiede sind zwischen den Orbits. Also Herschel ging zum Beispiel in einen sogenannten Large Halo Orbit. Und das ist einfach die Größe des Orbits, den man um diesen Punkt fliegt. Das ist relativ interessant.
Also die unterscheiden sich dann wiederum signifikant.
Die unterscheiden sich ja vor allem, wie man das Raumfahrzeug dahin fliegen kann, also den Satelliten. Bei Herschel braucht man zum Beispiel kein großes Manöver, um den Satelliten in den Orbit, um diesen Liberationspunkt zu bringen. Während wir bei Gaian einen relativ kleinen Orbit fliegen. Das ist so ein, wie soll man sagen, warum macht man das? Aufgrund bestimmter Technologien, die man auf dem Satelliten hat. Wie gesagt, Gaia ist eine ganz hochpräzisionsmission. Dann versucht man zum Beispiel, die Anzahl der beweglichen Teile, die an Bord sind, so gering wie möglich zu halten. Das heißt, Gaia hat zwar so ein Sonnenschild, aber das wird einmal ausgefahren. Danach ist eigentlich dieser Satellit fest. Das ist ein starrer Körper. Und Gaia hat eine sogenannte Phased Array Antenna. Das heißt, das ist keine Antenne, die sich irgendwie bewegt, sondern das ist ein Feld aus vielen Antennen. Und dadurch, dass man die Antennen mit einem leichten Versatz ansteuert, kann man sozusagen den Hauptstrahl der Antenne lenken, ohne was mechanisch bewegen zu müssen. Und das geht aber nur in bestimmten Bereichen. Das geht nicht besonders weit. Wir können den Strahl nicht beliebig weit ablenken. Und damit von Gaia aus die Erde immer in diesem Strahl drin ist, wird für Gaia der Orbit zum Beispiel sehr klein gemacht. Das heißt, wir fliegen nicht auf so einem großen Orbit. Das hat natürlich dann die Implikation, dass wir ein Manöver fliegen müssen. Für Gaia ein relativ großes, um den in diesem Orbit, um diesen Liberationspunkt zu bekommen, den Satelliten.
Ah, okay, verstehe. Das heißt, er hat eigentlich einen sehr eingeschränkten Blickwinkel, damit eben das einfach gebaut werden kann, damit sich nicht sehr viel drauf bewegt, weil das kann alles irgendwie Schwingungen verursachen, ungenau sein und überhaupt will man das nicht. Ist ja so ein bisschen wie bei Computern, da will man ja auch immer, dass sich nichts bewegt, da kommen wir ja auch so langsam hin, auch wenn die Gründe andere sind. Aber deswegen muss einfach so dieser Fleck, an dem er sich rumtreibt, einfach sehr kompakt sein.
Richtig, genau, damit einfach die Erde immer in diesem Antennenstrahl drin sein kann.
Wie kompakt ist der dann so?
Man gibt das immer im sogenannten Sonne-, Raumfahrzeug-, Erdewinkel an. Der ist 15 Grad beschränkt. Das hilft jetzt natürlich nicht besonders viel weiter.
Ich weiß nicht, wenn man da jetzt so eine Kugel drum spannen würde, die maximale Ausbreitung. Wie groß muss man sich das so vorstellen, die Sphäre, die er da befliegt?
Das ist schon noch relativ groß. Wir sind ja 1,5 Millionen Kilometer weit weg. Und haben dann schon noch Amplituden, die im 100.000er-Euro-Bereich sind. Äh, Euro. Also bei Gaia sind das zum Beispiel außerhalb der Ecliptik, also so um die 100.000 Kilometer und dann um die 300.000-400.000 Kilometer, die da schon noch um diesen Librationspunkt rumschwanken. Aber bei Herschel geht das zum Beispiel schon nahe an die Millionen ran. Also das sind schon relativ große Orbits, die man dann da um so nach unten.
Okay, also man kann mal so salopp sagen, der verbraucht nur 10% zu viel Platz da. Und dementsprechend ist der Anstrahlungs-Kommunikationswinkel auch kleiner.
Ja, also das ist, wie gesagt, das sind so 300.000, 400.000 Kilometer. Aber im Vergleich zu Herschel ist das ein gutes Stück kleiner.
So, jetzt haben wir also die Aufgabe, es soll halt vermessen werden. Damit diese Vermessung gut geschehen kann, muss sich das Ding selbst auch gut einordnen. Also fünf Jahre dieser Dauerfilm, wahrscheinlich der langweiligste Film der Welt.
Ich glaube, da sind einige Wissenschaftler anderer Meinung. Ich denke zwar nicht, dass sich ihn irgendjemand anschauen wird.
Auf jeden Fall. Da geschieht zwar eigentlich eine Menge, aber ist jetzt nicht so der Blockbuster. Aber diese fünf Jahre Universumsbeobachtung, die fallen dabei ab.
Das ganz Interessante ist, man bräuchte dafür schon einen ziemlich tollen Fernseher. Denn die Auflösung von der Digitalkamera ist dann nicht ein Megapixel, das ist dann schon eine Milliarde Pixel. Das heißt, man würde zumindest einen ziemlich schönen HD-HD-HD-Film bekommen.
Okay, aber das ist jetzt das Ziel. Jetzt wird demnächst irgendwie gestartet. Jetzt muss man erstmal hinfliegen, um dieses ganze Setup zu machen. Ich grüle jetzt gerade so ein bisschen, was man als nächstes betrachten sollte, weil das ist ja eigentlich alles irgendwie interessant. Aber da wir das jetzt schon erwähnt haben, bleiben wir doch vielleicht nochmal so bei dieser Herstellung dieser MESS-Situation. Das Ding wird jetzt gestartet werden von Kuru aus.
Wir starten von Französisch Kujana aus mit einer russischen Soyuz-Rakete. Die hat eine sogenannte Fregat-Oberstufe. Soyuz-Fregat heißt das System.
Genau, und wer es noch nicht mitbekommen hat, Soyuz ist ja eigentlich eine russische Rakete, die bisher immer nur in Baikonur gestartet ist und die ja jetzt umgebaut wurde, damit sie eben auch von Kourou, also nochmal selbe Raketenprinzip, aber eben angepasst auf die anderen Verhältnisse unten näher am Äquator.
Ja gut, wir haben in französisch Guiana einfach die Startrampe für die Soyuz gebaut. Genau. Jetzt fragt sich wahrscheinlich jemand, warum starten wir nicht direkt von Russland aus. Das hat natürlich Vorteile vom Äquator zu starten aufgrund der Erdrotation.
Da hat man einfach mehr Schmiss.
Genau, am Äquator ist einfach die Geschwindigkeit der Erde am schnellsten. Das heißt, wir nehmen die Geschwindigkeit einfach mit, um ins All zu kommen.
Das macht halt einfach alles billiger.
Die Rakete wird deswegen nicht billiger, aber wir können mehr Nutzlast hochschießen. Das heißt, die Satelliten, die wir hochschießen können, sind größer und damit können wir natürlich mehr Experimente bzw. bessere Experimente drauf machen. Deswegen ist natürlich der Science-Return dann, also der Wissenschaftserfolg meistens.
Ist Gaia groß?
Gaia, was ist groß? Also Gaia mit dem Sonnensegel ist schon groß. Man muss sich Gaia vorstellen einfach wie ein Hut. Gaia ist ein Zylinder, so ungefähr 3,5 Meter Durchmesser. Und dann entfaltet sich da noch unten sozusagen ein Sonnensegel, was dann 10 Meter ist. Also ist schon groß.
Ich meine groß im Sinne von, ist die Nutzlast hoch.
Ach so.
Also erfordert es jetzt sozusagen Kuru und eine hohe Nutzlast, um den da hochzubringen? Oder hätte man ihn nicht genauso gut auch in Russland hochschicken können?
Nee, das hätte nicht funktioniert. Man plant natürlich die Mission dann auch so, dass sie entsprechend gestartet werden können. Also man gibt natürlich dem Hersteller des Satelliten dann gewisse Vorgaben, wie schwer der Satellit sein darf. Und entsprechend werden die dann natürlich auch gebaut. Für Gaia war natürlich Soyuz von Kuru irgendwann festgelegt. Und von dem her wusste man dann auch, wie schwer der Satellit werden kann. Um sich das vorzustellen, Gaia wiegt jetzt 2,1 Tonnen ungefähr. Also 2100 Kilogramm. Aber was diese Rakete ins Albe fördern kann, ist natürlich vollkommen unterschiedlich. Man kann da natürlich viel schwerere Nutzlasten auf diese... Aber dann halt nicht so hoch. Genau. Man kommt einfach nicht so hoch. Und das Interessante an Gaia ist, dass die Fregatte Gaia am Schluss ja dann auf fast 1 Millionen Kilometer Entfernung beschleunigen muss. Und warum das jetzt nicht 1,5 Millionen Kilometer sind, ich weiß nicht, ob wir nachher noch mal über die Bahn sprechen, wie man da hinkommt.
Da kommen wir jetzt im Prinzip langsam hin. Darauf wollte ich eigentlich hinaus.
Das ist nämlich dann auch noch mal sehr interessant. Gehen wir einfach mal in den Start durch. Was da so passiert, nach dem Start. Oder wie man da überhaupt hinkommt. Das ist ja alles gar nicht so einfach. Wir starten ja auch zu einer bestimmten Sekunde am Tag. Das muss natürlich sicherstellen, dass die Rakete in die richtige Richtung fliegt. Dass wir nicht auf den Liberationspunkt in L1 Richtung Sonne fliegen, sondern dass wir wirklich dahin kommen, wo wir hinwollen.
Man könnte ja theoretisch überall hinfliegen, aber dann bräuchte man quasi so eine Rakete mit bediebig viel Energie, und die ist halt noch nicht erfunden worden.
Leider, leider.
Also versucht man, sich so ein Startfenster zu wählen, wo einem die Erde, wenn man in die richtige Richtung hoch steckt, im Prinzip schon mal in die richtige Richtung schleudert.
Wir gehen mit der Soyuz erstmal in einen niedrigen Erdorbit sogar. Also wir gehen in eine Kreisbahn um die Erde, damit wir dann sozusagen den Abflugspunkt noch mal bestimmen können. Und die Fregat-Oberstufe, die driftet dann einfach mit Gaia vorne drauf, ein bisschen um die Erde. Und wenn die sozusagen die richtige Abflugsposition erreicht haben, dass es sozusagen Richtung Liberationspunkt geht, dann zündet die Fregat-Oberstufe noch mal und beschleunigt dann Gaia eben auf diese Bahn, die Gaia dann ungefähr eine Million Kilometer weit bringen würde.
Und warum hat man jetzt die Soyuz genommen und nicht eine Ariane zum Beispiel?
Na das liegt dann wirklich daran, dass man eben am Anfang diese Studien gemacht hat, wie schwer wird so eine Mission? Und da ist dann natürlich die Abwägung, ja, also es gibt dann eine sogenannte CDF-Studie, also Concurrent Design Facility. Da wird so ein Satellit zum ersten Mal entworfen und da wird geschaut, was brauchen wir denn, wie kann das dann alles zusammenpassen? Und dann kommt man natürlich auf eine gewisse Nutzlast. Und die lag dann natürlich ungefähr in dem Bereich von zwei Tonnen. Und dann entscheidet man sich eben für eine entsprechende Rakete. Und die Ariane 5 wäre einfach für diese Mission viel zu groß gewesen und wäre dann damit natürlich auch viel zu teuer gewesen. Würde man einfach dann so nicht machen. Und deswegen kommt man dann eben auf die entsprechende Rakete zur Mission. Man hat ja verschiedene Raketen zur Auswahl.
Ja, das ist ja jetzt quasi das Neue, weil das war ja bis vor Kurzem nicht so. Da war ja Coru ein reiner Ariane-Ort und jetzt gibt es ja drei verschiedene Raketen zur Auswahl. Also die Vega, die dritte, die wäre jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht in Frage gekommen, weil die ja nur für niedrige Missionen gedacht ist. Aber Soyuz und Ariane decken sozusagen unterschiedliche Missionsaspekte ab.
Genau. Und das hat man natürlich früher ein bisschen auch versucht, mit der Ariane 4 schon zu schaffen. Die war ja verschieden konfigurierbar. Da konnte man ja unterschiedliche Booster außen anbauen. Aber jetzt ist das eigentlich ein wunderschönes Launcher-Assemble. Wir haben die kleine Vega. Wir haben die Soyuz für die mittleren Nutzlasten. Und dann haben wir die Ariane 5 als relativ großen Launcher.
Für die fetten Dinger.
Genau. Das liegt aber auch ein bisschen daran, was z.B. die Oberstufen können. Also von den Raketen. Wie flexibel die sind. Weil es ist z.B. nicht einfach, ein Triebwerk wieder zu starten im Weltall. Also so banal sich das anhört, das ist nicht unbedingt einfach. Und die Ariane 5 hat z.B. auch verschiedene Oberstufen, die man dann einsetzen kann. Und wird ja auch jetzt weiterentwickelt. Gerade, dass man eben da auch sehr viel Flexibilität hat. Und die Fregatte ist eine hervorragende Oberstufe. Also die kann wirklich sehr, sehr viele Dinge machen. Und ist auch entsprechend wiederzündbar. Wie gesagt, wir müssen ja diese Driftphase im Orbit haben, bevor sie dann entsprechend Gaia auf die finale Bahn einschießt. Und das spielt da natürlich auch eine Rolle. Was können die denn überhaupt?
Ja, so jetzt gehen wir mal davon aus, der Start hat super geklappt. Und es gibt auch hübsche Bilder ohne Nebel und so. Ist ja wahrscheinlich pro eh nicht so das Thema. Aber fliegt jetzt irgendwie los und ist jetzt erstmal in so einem Äquator-Orbit um die Erde herum. So und dann gucken wir nochmal, alles prima. Und dann wird so der Zeitpunkt definiert. Also das ist dann wahrscheinlich auch relativ offen. Da kann man irgendwie auch nochmal ein paar Tage dranhängen.
Das geht ganz schnell. Das ist alles vorher festgelegt. Also das muss auch, da ist man gar nicht so offen. Das muss schon Monate vorher festgelegt werden.
Aber der Lagrange-Punkt, der ändert sich ja in dem Sinne eigentlich gar nicht. Der ist doch immer an derselben Stelle relativ zu Erde. Ist es da nicht eigentlich ziemlich egal, wann man weiter fliegt?
Also das Problem ist, dieser Raketenstart muss relativ schnell erfolgen. Also auch, weil die Fregatte hat zum Beispiel keine Solarzellen. Die hat natürlich auch wenig Strom an Bord. Also man muss dann, wenn man startet, kann man auch in diesem Orbit, man driftet auch nicht in diesem vollen Orbit. Wie gesagt, das ist ein Bruchteil von so einem Orbit, den man um die Erde driftet, bis man eben an der richtigen Position ist. Da bleibt man wie gesagt nicht lange. Da geht man sofort raus. Das Problem ist, warum das immer unterschiedlich ist, ist zum Beispiel die Erdneigung. Unsere Erde ist ja um 23,5 Grad relativ zu Ekliptik. Also die Ekliptik ist die Ebene, in der sich die Erde um die Sonne bewegt. Und zu dieser Ebene, zu dieser Ekliptik, ist die Erdachse um 23,5 Grad geneigt.
Deswegen gibt es Sommer und Winter.
Deswegen gibt es Sommer und Winter. Und jetzt muss man sich natürlich vorstellen, fliegt die Rakete, wenn die losfliegt, natürlich nicht relativ zu der Ekliptik, was wir ja wollen. Denn der Liberationspunkt liegt ja in der Ekliptik. Und damit fliegt die natürlich relativ zu unserem Erdekvator. Und je nachdem, zu welcher Jahreszeit wir starten, ist das natürlich unterschiedlich. Und weil wir eben in diese Ekliptik oder nahe an die Ekliptik ran wollen, müssen wir sozusagen unterschiedliche Driftphasen festlegen. Das muss aber wiederum von dem Raketenhersteller implementiert werden. Also die müssen die Rakete ja entsprechend programmieren. Und müssen das ja auch testen. Und das dauert relativ lang. Und wir müssen sozusagen Flugprogramme bei Raketenhersteller bestellen. Also Flugprogramm sagt einfach, wo die Rakete letztendlich den Satelliten absetzt. Und die müssen dann Monate vorher entwickelt werden. Und das dauert natürlich. Das heißt, wir haben da nicht unbedingt Flexibilität. Und irgendwann schließt sich auch das Startfenster wieder. Weil wir einfach nicht mehr das richtige Programm haben. Das kann natürlich auch passieren. Also wenn jetzt massivste Verzögerungen auftreten...
Aber man könnte im Prinzip für jeden Tag im Jahr das richtige Programm machen.
Richtig. Also es gibt dann immer noch ein paar Probleme, wo man nicht fliegen kann. Weil der Mond einem einfach in die Quere kommt. Wenn man zum Migrationspunkt fliegt, irgendwann kommt der Mond durch. Das heißt, das Startfenster geht einmal im Monat zu. Man könnte das, genau wie du es beschrieben hast, für jeden Tag ein Flugprogramm entwickeln. Jetzt muss man aber wissen, dass diese Flugprogramme recht teuer sind und man sich deshalb auf sehr wenige Bündnisse beschränkt.
Aber jetzt verstehe ich auch die Zwänge. Auf der einen Seite ist es Geld, auf der anderen Seite ist es der Mond. Aber der Mond ist jetzt eigentlich auch das Einzige, was jetzt physikalisch in die Quere kommt. Die anderen Planeten spielen jetzt keine Rolle.
Nein, die anderen Planeten spielen keine Rolle.
Also geht es jetzt los. Das Ding wird abgesetzt und schießt dann aus diesem Orbit, also wird nicht abgesetzt, sondern ist in dieser kurzen Orbitphase um die Erde. Und dann im richtigen Punkt wird dann diese Oberstufe noch mal nachgezündet und dann geht es eine Million Kilometer immer geradeaus.
Ja, und jetzt wird es natürlich genau hier in Darmstadt super interessant. Weil jetzt beginnt dann natürlich unsere Aufgabe. Wir sind ja das Kontrollzentrum. Und jetzt ist die erste Herausforderung, den Satelliten erstmal zu finden. Das hört sich jetzt ein bisschen dumm an. Aber die Rakete, ich habe es vorhin ja so ein bisschen schon beschrieben, ist natürlich relativ brutal. Da ist wahnsinnig viel Energie am Werk. Und man kann sich natürlich vorstellen, wenn extrem viel Energie am Werk ist, ist man vielleicht nicht immer so ganz genau. Das heißt, die Rakete fliegt natürlich nicht exakt dahin, wo wir sie haben wollen. Und die setzt den Satelliten also jetzt ab. Aber der ist jetzt natürlich nicht genau an dem Punkt. Und jetzt gilt es natürlich, diesen Satelliten zu finden. Und das nennt man Acquisition of Signal. Also man muss das Signal von dem Satelliten finden. Das wird euch jetzt durch ein paar Dinge erschwert. Punkt eins, der Satellit wird abgesetzt. Und das passiert über Federn. Also das ist erstmal, ja, pyrotechnisch wird der freigesetzt. Und dann sind Federn da, die den von der Oberstufe abstoßen. Und man gibt sich dann natürlich wahnsinnig viel Mühe, das möglich gleichmäßig zu machen. Aber man kriegt das natürlich nicht hundertprozentig hin. Das heißt, im Zweifelsfall dreht sich der Satellit jetzt schon ein bisschen. Und der hat zwar Antennen auf den entsprechenden Seiten, aber er hat natürlich einen drehenden Satelliten, weiß nicht so ganz genau, wo der ist, und muss den jetzt erstmal finden. Und da haben wir zum Beispiel bei Gaia erstmal festgestellt, wo wir zum ersten Mal vom Launcher Authority, nennt sich das, also vom Hersteller der Rakete, die entsprechend die Soyos dann von Kuh aus fliegen, gibt es eine sogenannte Dispersionsmatrix. Die gibt einem vor, wo man erwarten kann, dass der Satellit dann ist. Und das haben wir uns dann mal so angeschaut, haben ausgerechnet und haben gesehen, jetzt haben wir sozusagen eine Antenne am Boden, die hat eine bestimmte Breite von ihrem Strahl. Und dann haben wir so festgestellt, irgendwie muss der Satellit jetzt aber nicht unbedingt in dem Strahl drin sein, weil das einfach unerwartet hoch war. Und das sind dann so die spannenden Sachen. Ja, was macht man denn dann? Wie finden wir jetzt unseren Satelliten da oben, wenn der dann gestartet wurde? Natürlich geht es in den meisten Fällen richtig gut, aber wir reden hier ja über sehr, sehr viel Geld. Und dann kann man nicht sagen, ja, da wird schon gut gehen, der wird schon da sein ungefähr. Man muss da halt super gut vorbereitet sein. Und dann entsprechend nach den Mittel und Möglichkeiten suchen, wie wir ihn kriegen, wann wir ihn kriegen.
Das ist aber jetzt auch nicht Gaia spezifisch besonders schwer, sondern das ist eigentlich ein generelles Problem.
Das ist jetzt für Gaia schon ein bestimmtes Problem, weil Gaia in einem bestimmten Frequenzband sendet, nämlich das X-Band, das ist relativ hochfrequent. Und damit sind sozusagen die Strahlweiten, also die Breite von dem Strahl von so einer Bodenstation, sehr, sehr klein, die ihr findet.
Also es ist ja generell im Einsatz bei solchen Fernen.
Ja, aber was es sonst eben gibt, ist dieses S-Band. Und da ist das normalerweise kein so großes Problem. Und so ist das zum Beispiel, dass jetzt in... Also die Station, die wir jetzt eben für diese Acquisition of Signal, für diesen Erstkontakt benutzen, ist in Westaustralien. Ist die Station in Perth, genau. Und wenn man sich zum Beispiel die Bilder im Internet anschaut von Perth, wird man feststellen, dass eine Satellitenschüssel, die 15 Meter groß ist, also schon eine ganz gewaltige Antenne, da sitzt dann aber jetzt oben auf der 15-Meter-Antenne noch eine ganz, ganz kleine Antenne drauf. Das ist dann das Expand Acquisition Aid, nennt sich das. Und das ist einfach die Antenne, die einfach einen viel, viel breiteren Fächer hat. Und mit der man dann sozusagen einen Satelliten, der dann eben nicht ganz so genau bestimmt ist am Anfang, finden kann. Und die hat man dann einfach sozusagen auf die Bodenstation aufgesetzt. Zwar für eine andere Mission, also für Lisa Papfeiler, auch eine Liberationspunktmission, geht allerdings an L1. Und die muss man dann entsprechend benutzen, um eben den Satelliten oben zu finden.
Also im schlimmsten Fall würde man es schon irgendwie herausgeschnuppert bekommen sozusagen.
Ja, da gibt es dann natürlich noch andere Möglichkeiten. Also man macht dann, man kann da natürlich bestimmte Suchalgorithmen machen.
Und vor allem im schlimmsten Fall wäre es ja auch nicht nur eine Bodenstation, sondern dann wird wahrscheinlich überall auf dem ganzen Planeten, was so halbwegs in die richtige Richtung zeigt, alles eingeschaltet, was zu holen ist.
Ja, wobei das gar nicht so einfach ist. Weil natürlich die Bodenstationen alle in andere Richtungen gucken vom Himmel. Und der Satellit ist zu dem Zeitpunkt ja noch relativ niedrig. Das heißt, man sieht ihn noch von gar nicht so vielen Bodenstationen aus.
Weil man jetzt überhaupt nicht weiß, wo er ist.
Nein, natürlich ist ganz klar. Aber man hat noch andere Möglichkeiten. Also ist ganz klar, zum Beispiel die Fregattoberstufe selber sendet natürlich auch ein Signal aus. Und die macht das zum Beispiel im S-Band. Und natürlich sind nach der Separation von Gaia und der Fregattoberstufe die beiden sehr nahe beieinander.
Das heißt, in etwa wird man's dann eh schon wissen und dann kriegt man den Rest auch noch irgendwie.
Und um ganz beruhigt zu sein, inzwischen ist man natürlich auch viel weiter. Man hat die Bahnen nochmal viel genauer untersucht, auch von Raketenhersteller. Also das ist ja auch eine neue Bahn, für die muss man sagen. Deswegen kann man da von Anfang an nicht Topwerte erwarten. Dass es wie ein Satellit einmalig ist, ist auch diese Bahn einmalig, die wir jetzt fliegen. Und die müssen das natürlich auch konsolidieren. Deswegen entwickeln die das ja auch über Monate vorher. Und am Ende ist alles halb so wild. Also die Dispersion, die wir da bekommen, ist viel kleiner, als wir am Anfang dachten. Das heißt, das sollte kein großes Problem sein, Gaia für uns am Himmel zu finden. Was natürlich super ist, macht die Sache nochmal ein bisschen sicherer.
So, jetzt muss eine Million Kilometer lang gefeuert werden und das letzte Halbe wird dann einfach von alleine geflogen, oder?
Gefeuert ja nicht. Der Satellit driftet ja die meiste Zeit. Also erstmal die Fregatte beschleunigt den Satelliten soweit, dass er eben fast eine Million Kilometer weiter herauskommen könnte. Warum nicht eineinhalb Millionen Kilometer, wo wir eigentlich hin wollen? Und das ist sehr Gaia spezifisch. Denn Gaia hat ein Antriebssystem, was nur für längere Zeit von der Sonne weg beschleunigen kann. Also sobald Gaia im Orbit ist, das erste was passiert, das wird das Sonnen, ja, Sunshields, auf Deutsch der Sonnenschirm sozusagen, entfaltet, auf dem die Solarzellen sind. Und damit ist eigentlich die Richtung von Gaia, also die Lage von Gaia, die Ausrichtung zur Sonne vorgeschrieben. Also die Solarzellen zeigen in erster Näherung mal zur Sonne. Man kann dann schon noch abweichen, so 45 Grad Winkel ist erlaubt. Weiter geht nicht, weil sonst die Teleskope in die Sonne schauen würden. Also man kann den Satelliten nicht mehr drehen. Und jetzt ist es eben sehr interessant, dass natürlich der Treibstoff in den Tanks ist. Und wenn man jetzt die Triebwerke zündet und Gaia von der Sonne wegfliegt sozusagen, also wenn man weiter beschleunigt, dann sammelt sich der Treibstoff natürlich unten in den Tanks, was super ist. Also er ist weiterhin am Auslass, da, wo man ihn haben will.
Das ist ja auch so ein generelles Problem mit Flüssigkeiten und Weltraum. Die machen dann, was sie wollen. Und so schiebt man quasi den Sprit an die richtige Stelle.
So passiert das auch bei einer Rakete, die beschleunigt die ganze Zeit. Also ist der Treibstoff genau da, wo man ihn haben will. Wenn das jetzt aber so ist, dass wir Gaia wieder in Richtung Sonne schicken wollten, also wir wollten nicht auf diese 1 Mio. km, sondern wir wollten theoretisch z.B. nur 500.000 km. Dann müssten wir den Satelliten bremsen. Und in Richtung der Sonne feuern. Das können wir machen. Dann zünden wir die Triebwerke. Aber dann passiert das Folgende. Dann geht der Treibstoff in die andere Richtung und ist nicht mehr da, wo man ihn haben will. Dann geht das nur für sehr kurze Impulse. Man kann dann das Triebwerk kurz feuern und muss dann wieder in ungefähr eine Stunde warten, bis der Treibstoff wieder sich gesammelt hat, an den richtigen Stellen ist. Dann müsste man das nächste Mal überfliegen. Und deswegen, damit man absolut auf der sicheren Seite ist, dass man Gaia nie sozusagen bremsen muss, bremsen hört sich ein bisschen komisch an im Weltall, aber dass man immer von der Sonne weg beschleunigt, hat man die Rakete eben nicht genau bis zum Librationspunkt fliegen lassen. Sondern lässt Gaia das letzte Stück machen. Das heißt, Gaia fliegt ungefähr zwischen 27 Stunden und 48 Stunden nach Separation, fliegt Gaia nochmal manöver und zündet die Triebwerke und macht genau das, beschleunigt den Satelliten weiter raus, sodass wir dann wirklich zum Librationspunkt kommen, wo wir wirklich hinwollen. Und das macht man eben nur, damit man auf jeden Fall vermeidet, dass man Gaia jemals abbremsen müsste.
Das heißt, das ist jetzt, hätte man jetzt bei Planck und Herschl nicht genau das gleiche Problem gehabt?
Das hängt eben damit zusammen, wie man so ein Antriebssystem designt. Und das ist eben jetzt Gaia spezifisch, das ist eben nicht ganz einfach.
Also das Antriebsdesign ist explizit anders.
Und deswegen kann man zum Beispiel auch die Raketenaufstiegsbahn natürlich nicht für einen anderen Satelliten verwenden. Weil ein anderer Satellit hat wiederum ein anderes Design von einem Antriebssystem, verwendet vielleicht ein vollkommen anderes Antriebssystem, hat die Triebwerke anders angeordnet. Das sind eben alles Einzelproduktionen.
Andere Rakete.
Und deswegen braucht man dann eben schon wieder andere Voraussetzungen.
Das ist dann aber sozusagen jetzt auch schon die Geschichte des Anflugs. Also so eine Million Kilometer macht es diese Oberstufe. Und danach kümmert sich Gaia selbst drum.
Wie gesagt, das erste Manöver findet 27-48 Stunden nach Separation statt. Und dann driftet Gaia natürlich erstmal wieder. Das braucht eine Weile, bis man zum Liberationspunkt kommt. Das ist auch wieder ein bisschen saisonal abhängig, wie eben die Konstellation der Erdachse ist. Und das dauert jetzt ungefähr 20 Tage, also Pi mal Raum, drei Wochen, bis man am Liberationspunkt ankommt. Und dann hatten wir ja vorhin drüber geredet, aufgrund des Antennendesigns von Gaia muss dann nochmal ein Manöver geflogen werden, das man eben in so einen kleinen Liberationspunkt-Orbit einschwenkt. Und das ist auch zeitkritisch, weil man natürlich sonst am Liberationspunkt entsprechend vorbei fliegen würde. Und ist natürlich auch kritisch von der Planung, weil man fliegt ja, man hat den Satelliten ja noch nicht oft geflogen sozusagen. Man hat auch noch nicht so super viel Erfahrung damit. Und man muss jetzt auch mit diesem Manöver natürlich sicherstellen, dass es so genau ist, dass die Korrektur des Manövers nicht in diese Sonnenrichtung geht. Also muss man diese Manöver auch wieder sehr, sehr genau planen. Und wenn dann auch irgendwas passieren sollte, muss man natürlich sehr, sehr schnell reagieren, damit man entsprechend die Korrekturmaßnahmen ergreifen kann. Weil man muss dazu sagen, zu dieser Liberationspunkt-Umgebung, die ist instabil. Also wenn man Satelliten nicht die ganze Zeit dort kontrolliert, dann fliegt er einfach wieder raus. Also das ist nicht so, dass die Satelliten wie hier um die Erde kreisen, wenn sie mal oben sind. Und auch wenn man sozusagen nichts macht, bleiben die erst mal oben. Sondern Liberationspunkt-Satelliten, die werden einfach da entsprechend rausgekippt.
Weil da ist ja jetzt nichts, was selber noch mal Gravitation entwickelt. Es ist ja nicht so, dass dieser Punkt einen magisch anziehen würde, wie das ein großes Objekt tut. Sondern es ist nur quasi, ja, es gibt so einen theoretischen Punkt, wo sich alles aufhebt. Aber wenn man auch nur ein paar Meter an der falschen Stelle ist, gewinnt irgendwas anderes auch schon wieder ein bisschen die Überhand und dann verstärkt sich das voneinander.
Vollkommen richtig. Man kann sich das vorstellen, wie so ein Bleistift, den man auf seiner Fingerspitze balanciert. Man muss die ganze Zeit leicht nachkorrigieren. Und dann, je nachdem, wann man mal nicht korrigiert, fällt er nach links oder nach rechts. Und entsprechend Gaia, wenn man nichts macht, also wir machen alle 30 Tage was bei Gaia, wir korrigieren die Bahn, fällt er eben entsprechend zurück zur Erde oder fällt raus ins Sonnensystem und ist weg.
Aber das würde doch irgendwie auch bedeuten, dass man jetzt um diese Lissajour-Figur da fliegen zu können, um diesen Punkt herum. Hat man ja eigentlich nichts, worum man jetzt so richtig herum orbiten kann. Also nichts, was einen jetzt mit der Gravitation sozusagen irgendwie hält. Das heißt, man muss auch die ganze Zeit Sprit verbrauchen?
Ja. Also das ist auch, man braucht die ganze Zeit Sprit, ist es so. Und Satelliten dort sind lebensdauerbeschränkt. Also es bleibt einfach nichts dort. Die Punkte, ja, entsorgen sozusagen den Müll am Schluss.
Mehr oder weniger selbst. Was aber nicht heißt, dass sie nicht doch am Schluss nochmal in sichere Gefilde überführt werden.
Genau.
Damit sie nicht dann doch aus irgendwelchen Gründen dann so energien rum.
Natürlich macht man das ja. Also da gibt ja Space Debris Mitigation, also Weltraum, Schrott, Vermeidung.
Bitte hinterlassen sie das Universum, wie sie es vorzufinden wünschen.
Vollkommen richtig. Man versucht natürlich, hinter sich aufzuräumen und alles sauber zu hinterlassen. Das ist ganz klar. Aber es ist vollkommen richtig. Wir brauchen die ganze Zeit Treibstoff. Also wir müssen wirklich alle 30 Tage in Manöver fliegen, damit Gaia sozusagen weiter in diesem Orbit um den Liberationspunkt bleibt. Das haben aber Liberationspunktmissionen allgemein so an sich um den Liberationspunkt 1 oder um den Liberationspunkt 2.
Kommen wir nochmal so ein bisschen auf die eigentliche Tätigkeit zurück. Jetzt haben wir ja schon viel über die eigentlichen Ziele geredet, aber nur so teilweise darüber, wie die denn jetzt eigentlich dann letztlich auch erzielt werden. Also klar, es soll halt gefilmt werden. Ich frage mich jetzt die ganze Zeit, womit eigentlich? Also welche Instrumente sind jetzt Gaia mit so mitgegeben worden, um das durchzuführen? Es gab da ja auch so eine etwas, so eine komische Konfusion mit dem Namen, dass das Ding gar nicht mehr so richtig benannt ist, weil man dann so auf halben Wege die Technik dann noch mal gewechselt hat.
Ja, ein I in Gaia sollte mal für Interferometrie stehen, aber es ist gar kein Interferometer mehr an Bord. Also man macht das jetzt anders. Gaia ist jetzt einfach der Eigenname tatsächlich. Ja. Man verwendet das nicht mehr als Abkürzung. Ja, das Instrument an Bord von Gaia sind zwei Teleskope, die mit einem relativ großen Winkel zwischen einander eben genau, sagen wir mal, diesen Film aufnehmen. Diesen großen Winkel zwischen Teleskopen macht man deshalb, damit man die Positionsgenauigkeit der Sterne einfach verbessert. Ja, das ist einfach die Relativgeometrie, dass man einen Stern, den man mit dem einen Teleskop beobachtet, sage ich mal mit einem Stern in einem relativ großen Winkelabstand mit kartografieren kann. Es liegt einfach an der Geometrie, dass das damit die Karte verbessert. Das Instrument selber ist ein riesiges Feld von CCDs. Ich glaube, es sind 106 CCD-Chips mit eben einer Gesamtauflösung von einer Milliarde Pixeln. Das ist eine ganz gewaltige CCD-Kamera. Und es ist auch relativ groß. Das muss man sich nicht so wie eine kleine CCD-Kamera vorstellen, sondern es ist schon Meter mit CCD-Feldern. Das ist schon ein ziemlich großes Instrument. Und wie gesagt, Gaia dreht sich...
Damit auch der einzelne Pixel möglichst groß ist, damit auch viel Licht reinfallen kann. Das ist ja immer so das Problem bei der ganzen Miniaturisierung. Jeder hat CCDs in seinem Telefon mittlerweile, natürlich auch in jeder Digitalkamera. Aber in dem Moment, wo es platzsparend ausgeführt ist, heißt auch, dass relativ wenig Licht reinfällt und das erzeugt dann Rauschen.
Das Rauschen, ja, weil eben viel Hintergrundrauschen da ist. Aber genau dieses Rauschen zu vermeiden ist Gaia zum Beispiel auch so weit weg, damit es eben genau konstante Obgebungsbedingungen hat. Aber das ist natürlich vollkommen richtig. Also je kleiner der Chip ist, desto anfälliger ist er sozusagen für das thermische Rauschen auch. Und je größer der Chip ist, desto besser ist bei Nacht bei einer CCD-Kamera auch die Aufnahme. Und wir haben natürlich, wenn wir den Himmel anschauen, natürlich beständig Nacht. Jetzt ist es so, dass vorne eine Reihe an CCDs ist, wo der Stern natürlich erstmal drüber geht. Und das wird sozusagen zu vermessen für den Onboard-Computer bei Gaia. Da wird dann natürlich festgestellt, da ist also jetzt ein Stern. Und der kann natürlich zum Beispiel sehr hell sein. Da haben wir vorher gesprochen drüber. Oder er kann extrem dunkel sein, also ein ganz, ganz feiner Fleck. Und entsprechend wird natürlich das Feld hinten darauf vorbereitet, was da für ein Stern kommt, damit man den auch entsprechend vermessen kann. Und der läuft dann eben über dieses CCD-Feld und kann dadurch eben entsprechend kartografiert werden. Also es ist natürlich nicht nur einer. Es sind wahnsinnig viele Sterne auf einmal auf diesem CCD-Feld. Vor allem wenn wir zum Beispiel ins Zentrum der Galaxis schauen. Und entsprechend muss auch der Onboard-Computer von Gaia natürlich ausgelegt sein, dass er diese Vielzahl von Sternen auf diesen Chips entsprechend verarbeiten kann. Und dann kommt eben dieses Feld, bei dem die Position der Sterne bestimmt wird, relativ zueinander. Das ist diese Astrometrie. Und danach kommen nochmal Felder, womit wir eben die Spektroskopie machen können. Und da wird sich dann eigentlich die Farbe der Sterne angeschaut. Also das ist zwar keine extrem hochauflösende Spektroskopie, aber man kann durchaus eben Rot und Blau entsprechend dann vermessen. Und was dann noch kommt, und das ist sehr interessant, wir hatten ja über die 3D-Position der Sterne gesprochen, dass man auch wissen will, wie weit weg er ist, beziehungsweise wie schnell er sich weg bewegt. Dann wird nochmal auf einem Feld die Radialgeschwindigkeit vermessen. Und das wird dadurch gemacht, dass man sich Spektrallinien anschaut, also die bei jedem Stern entsprechend vorhanden sind. Und das ist jetzt das gleiche Prinzip, wie wir feststellen, ob sich ein Satellit von uns weg bewegt oder ob sich ein Satellit zu uns her bewegt. Diese Spektrallinie von einem Element ist entweder ins rote verschoben oder von der Wellenlänge her ins blaue verschoben. Und genau wie wir sozusagen dann wissen, aha, der Satellit bewegt sich von uns weg. Wenn sich diese Dopplerverschiebung in den Radiowellen messen lässt, lässt sich über diese Verschiebung der Spektrallinie dann feststellen, ob sich der Stern jetzt von uns weg bewegt oder zu uns bewegt. Und jetzt haben wir natürlich noch nicht die...
Das kann man aber nur deshalb machen, weil man jetzt, also sagen wir mal, man sieht jetzt so in so einen Stern rein. Was kann man da sehen? Also Helium und irgendwie noch ein paar andere Elemente. Und da ist jetzt, sagen wir mal, irgendein Element und das hat so ein typisches Muster in diesem Spektrum.
Vollkommen richtig.
Und man erkennt sozusagen das Muster als solches, aber man sieht, naja, eigentlich müsste es so ein bisschen weiter links verschoben sein. Also können wir da eine Geschwindigkeit auch noch herausrechnen. Das kann man auch erst, nachdem man quasi diese Elemente erkannt hat.
Vollkommen richtig. Aber das ist natürlich dieses, also jedes Element hat so einen ganz, ganz charakteristischen Fingerprint, so einen Fingerabdruck, wie sich das in diesen Spektrallinien auswirkt.
Und das kann man dann sowohl zur Bestimmung der, ja das sind die Elemente, die es da gibt und weil wir sie sehen, können wir jetzt auch sagen.
Gut, aber das verwenden wir jetzt nicht um, also dieses Element wird nicht dazu verwendet, um volle Spektroskopie zu machen, sondern wirklich nur um diese Radial-Komponente. Um diese Positionierung. Das ist auf ein Element beschränkt, sage ich mal, auf einen Abdruck, der eben sehr spezifisch ist.
Macht denn Gaia selbst jetzt aus diesem Bild auch irgendeine Auswertung oder ist es einfach nur Rohdaten?
Es sind natürlich sehr viele Rohdaten. Gaia versucht natürlich, diesen Riesen-Messintervall anzupassen. Aber es schickt dann die Daten schon entsprechend als Rohdaten zum Großteil.
da wird dann nur Kompression drüber gemacht, damit es möglichst wenig Daten sind und dann ab dafür.
Dann kommt das zurück zur Erde.
Wie häufig muss das Ding abgeschöpft werden, damit es da nicht überläuft?
Na ja, das ist täglich. Also Gaia, das ist ja das Schöne am Liberationspunkt. Das ist ja immer am Nachthimmel.
Immer auf der dunklen Seite der Nacht.
Genau, immer auf der dunklen Seite der Nacht. Und dadurch, dass Gaia dann auch so weit weg ist, hat man natürlich auch relativ lange Kommunikationsperioden. D.h. man sieht natürlich Gaia relativ lange in der Nacht. Das sind schon ein paar Stunden, die man im Satellit sieht. Jetzt kommt natürlich dazu, dass wir hier in Darmstadt sind. Und ich glaube, die meisten Leute mögen nicht nachts arbeiten. Es ist natürlich ein Riesenvorteil, dass wir Bodenstationen auch in Australien haben. D.h. wenn es hier in Darmstadt natürlich Tag ist, ist es in Australien natürlich Nacht. Und unsere Bodenstation in Australien zeigt dann natürlich entsprechend Richtung Liberationspunkt und kann dann natürlich...
Also den Datenstaubsauger auf der anderen Seite des Planeten.
Genau.
Und betreibt das sozusagen dort immer im Dunkeln. Aber man könnte doch schon noch jetzt die Erfassungsmenge erhöhen, indem man jetzt mit mehr als nur dem Perth-Teleskop arbeitet.
Also die Bodenstation ist dann nicht mehr Perth, nämlich die ist interessanterweise zu klein. Also man geht dann auf das sogenannte Deep Space Network. Die entsprechende Antenne steht dann aber gar nicht so weit weg. Die steht in New Norcia. Das ist dann aber weiter in der Wüste drin, damit es weniger Interferenzen gibt.
Weil Perth ist ja schon so ein bisschen da, wächst so die Stadt an.
Richtig. Und die Station ist auch entsprechend größer. Das ist dann eine der 35-Meter-Schüsseln, die wir haben.
Okay.
Und die sind über die Welt verteilt. Wir haben eine in Madrid, in Cebreos. Eine in Westaustralien, das ist New Norcia. Und die dritte ist jetzt sehr neu in Argentinien, in Malagüe.
Das heißt, die kommen auch alle zum Einsatz?
Malagüe, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wie man das ausspricht. Die kommen nicht alle zum Einsatz. Also entsprechend für die Missionen werden die zugeteilt.
Aber sie könnten zum Einsatz kommen, wenn es z.B. irgendein Problem gibt, wo man dann vielleicht auch mal nachts arbeiten würde.
Es gibt natürlich immer die Backup-Station, klar. Das sollte ja auch kein Single Point of Failure sein. Also wenn eine Station ausfällt, sollte natürlich ein Zufriedener.
Ich meine, angenommen die Kommunikation würde jetzt irgendwie wegbrechen.
Das kann ja immer ein Problem geben.
Wie lange kann der Satellit Daten zwischenspeichern, bevor irgendwas verloren geht?
Nein, das ist normalerweise nicht so viel. Ich muss jetzt sagen, ich würde auf zwei Tage tippen, aber ich weiß es nicht wunderbar. Aber zwei Tage ist normalerweise so ein ganz typisches Ding, dass man sagt, da kriegt man erstmal eine andere Station, zumindest um Teil runterzuladen, beziehungsweise, dass man auch eine Station wieder fit bekommt. Ich meine, man muss es sehen, das wird ja alles entsprechend auch eingeplant mit den anderen Missionen. Das Gaia ist ja nicht die einzige Mission, die jetzt Daten sozusagen für längere Zeit empfängt. Von dem her wird das alles vorher geplant. Die Stationen haben ja auch ganz normal mal Auszeiten. Die müssen ja auch mal gewartet werden, entsprechend repariert werden oder für neue Missionen vorbereitet werden. Man geht ja jetzt in höhere Frequenzbänder. Das heißt, irgendwann muss so eine Station ja mal für Carband vorbereitet werden. Von dem her gibt es ganz normale Ausfälle. Das heißt, man schaltet dann schon auf eine andere Mission und das wird eben entsprechend alles geplant. Und ein Ding ist natürlich, man kann das, Gaia hat ja auch mal mehr und mal weniger Daten. Entsprechend, wenn man zum Beispiel ins galaktische Zentrum schaut, sind natürlich wahnsinnig viel mehr Sterne, als wenn man jetzt entsprechend rausschaut.
Aber schaut man nicht sowieso die ganze Zeit überall hin? Ich meine, wenn er sich denkt, alle sechs Stunden dreht, dann...
Ja, aber er dreht sich ja, sag ich mal, also in erster Näherung dreht er sich ja erst mal um eine Achse. Und die Achse muss ja jetzt nicht unbedingt, also beziehungsweise wenn diese Achse zum galaktischen Zentrum zeigt, sind die beiden Teleskope ja sozusagen 90° versetzt. Das heißt, er schaut sich genau das dann zu dieser Zeitpunkt nicht an. Man würde dann natürlich entsprechend einplanen, mal mehr, mal weniger Daten geben.
Verstehe. Das heißt, man könnte dann auch zur Not die Daten dadurch reduzieren, indem man einfach mal langweiligere...
Man kann es natürlich, also man schaut natürlich, es ist natürlich vorgegeben über den Orbit, beziehungsweise die Position, wo man sich gerade befindet, was man anschaut. Also das... Man hat da, man kann das Spacecraft natürlich, also den Satelliten, man fällt immer ins Englische zurück, das ist zu schlimm.
Das ist hier so normal, wo man gleich so danach denkt.
Man hat da natürlich schon... Man könnte die Freiheit nutzen, aber natürlich ist das erst mal ja eine Beobachtung, die angestoßen wird. Das Raumfahrzeug rotiert und schaut sich bestimmte Regionen an. Und dann ist diese Achse um die Gaia rotiert. Die bewegt sich wiederum in 63 Tagen noch mal in so einer Präzisionsbewegung. Aber das ist eigentlich schon sehr gut geplant, damit man natürlich das erfüllt, dass man jeden Stern 70-mal beobachtet. Und diese 70-mal ist auch wichtig. Muss ich jetzt noch mal kurz zurückspringen. Wir hatten vorhin die Radialgeschwindigkeit. Jetzt braucht man sozusagen noch die Geschwindigkeit der Sterne, wie sie sich eben nicht radial bewegen, sondern wie sie sich im Himmel bewegen. Das kriegt man natürlich nur dadurch hin, dass man sich 70-mal hintereinander den Stern anguckt. Und an verschiedenen Zeiten über diese fünf Jahre. Nur so kann man dann die Geschwindigkeit der Sterne ausrechnen.
Aber letztlich, wenn da mal ein Tag fehlen würde, das wäre jetzt auch nicht gleich das Ende der Mission.
Nein, überhaupt nicht. Das muss man ja auch vorsehen. Es gibt ja viele Dinge, die einen Satelliten mal durcheinanderbringen können. Sonnenwind. Ja, Sonnenwind. Also so ein relativ starker Sonnensturm, wenn das passiert. Da kommen ja relativ viele Partikel. Die schlagen auf dem Satelliten ein. Der Sternensensor wird da durch der CCD überladen. Da sieht er einen Stern, wo gar kein Stern ist. Also sagt er, ich weiß gerade nicht mehr, wo ich bin. Also sag ich, okay, hier irgendwas stimmt nicht. Und dann geht der Satelliten in den sogenannten Safe Mode. Das heißt, er hat grobe Sensoren, die richten ihn aus, dass er schön zur Sonne zeigt, dass alles sicher ist, dass auf keinen Fall das Teleskop beschädigt wird. Und damit muss man einfach rechnen. Das ist aber auch eingeplant. Also das kann jedem Satelliten passieren. Also diese hundertprozentige Verfügbarkeit gibt es nicht. Das ist ganz klar. Also es kann ja auch am Boden was schiefgehen. Auch bei uns in ESOC kann ja auch mal sein, dass es dann einen ganz gravierenden Fehler gibt, der das Zentrum hier mal für einen Tag, für zwei außer Betrieb setzt. Natürlich hat man diesen Puffer auf dem Satelliten, dass der durchaus mal was zwischenspeichern kann. Aber das ist jetzt keine Woche. Also davon gehe ich mal aus. Wie gesagt, ich kenne die genaue Zahl nicht, aber zwei Tage ist normalerweise so ein ganz vernünftiger Ansatz. Aber Safe-Modes passieren. Also das ist bei jedem Satelliten der Fall. Und ist auch so vorhergesehen.
Manchmal geht ja auch in der Planung was schief. Das soll ja auch vorgekommen sein schon.
Ja, in der Planung, was heißt schief gehen? Diese Dinge ändern sich eben.
Aber es gab ja eine Verschiebung. Gaia hätte ja im Prinzip eigentlich schon unterwegs sein sollen. Nichts richtig erinnere, oder?
Ja, Gaia hätte eigentlich vorgestern starten sollen. Ja, das ist eigentlich Glück, muss man sagen.
Also vorgestern wäre der 23. November 2013 gewesen uns hier auch mal so in der Zeit mal so ein bisschen zu kalibrieren.
Ja, und bei Gaia, wir haben vorhin schon wirklich Transponder geredet, die verwendet werden, um eben mit dem Satelliten zu kommunizieren. Und da ist jetzt, muss man ja sagen, zum Glück, na ja zum Glück für uns, für den anderen nicht so glücklich, auf einem anderen Satelliten, der bereits im Orbit ist, ein Problem aufgetreten mit eben diesem Transponder, der dazu dient, mit dem Satelliten zu kommunizieren.
Also nur mit einem einzigen Bauteil.
Mit einem einzigen Bauteil. Das hat man aber dann erst natürlich, erst mal gab es das Problem. Und dann musste natürlich erst mal rausgefunden werden am Boden, okay, was ist denn jetzt das Problem? Und das dauerte natürlich relativ lang. Erst mal rauszufinden, was ist denn da jetzt wirklich kaputt gegangen? Und das ist dann erfolgt. Und dann fand man zufälligerweise heraus, dass bei Gaia genau das gleiche Bauteil verbaut worden ist in den Transpondern. Und dass das auch zu diesem Ausfall hätte führen können. Und das ist natürlich auch so...
Da gehen gleich alle Alarmglocken an.
Da gehen alle Alarmglocken an. Und natürlich wurde dann gesagt, okay, das Risiko gehen wir nicht ein, dass jetzt irgendwas mit diesem Transponder passiert. Weil das ist der Kontakt zum Satelliten. Also was bringt einen der schönste Satelliten, wenn man nicht mit ihm sprechen kann? Und es wurde dann eben sehr kurzfristig gesagt, okay, das Risiko gehen wir nicht ein. Das muss repariert werden. Und das Problem ist natürlich, dass Gaia schon zusammengebaut war, für einen Start vorher vorgesehen war, ist auch schon in Kourou, also in Französisch Guiana.
Also wie kurz vor dem Start ist diese Entscheidung gefällt worden?
Ja, so einen Monat vor dem Start.
Da ist eigentlich alles fertig.
Da ist eigentlich alles fertig, ja. Also, ja, grober Monat war. Ich glaube, es war ein bisschen mehr. Er war schon in Kourou? Er war schon in Kourou.
Das heißt, er musste wieder rauf aufs Schiff?
Nee, also man hat jetzt wirklich den Satelliten in Kourou sozusagen so weit auseinander genommen, dass man an diese beiden Boxen rankommt.
Das ist interessant, das wusste ich gar nicht. Also, das ist schon an dem Weltraumbahnhof, gibt es die Facilities, um auch nochmal Satelliten zu fixen. Ich meine, das kann man ja nicht in jeder beliebigen Lagerhalle machen. Da braucht man ja zumindest so gewisse Anforderungen an Reinraum und Staub und Hitze, Wetter, keine Ahnung, was da alles noch eine Rolle spielen mag.
Das ist in Kuhn natürlich vorhanden. Weil die Satelliten kommen ja dann entsprechend in den Containern an, müssen ja dann auch vorbereitet werden.
Auch korrekt gelagert werden. Genau. Okay, die Anforderungen für Lagerung reichen jetzt auch schon fast für Reparatur auch aus.
Ja, also es ist natürlich ein Reinraum. Man hat die Satelliten natürlich jetzt nicht dort reparieren können, aber man hat die beiden Boxen ausbauen können.
Man könnte sozusagen die Komponente ausbauen und die wurden dann verschickt.
Die wurden dann zurückgeschickt und wurden dann repariert. Und sind jetzt in den Sprit, also sind auch wieder nach Kuru zurückgeflogen worden. Und seit heute ist der Satellit auch wieder zusammengesetzt und schon getestet. Also die Reparatur ist soweit erfolgreich. Und ist jetzt sozusagen, der Satellit ist wieder startbereit. Ich glaube im Moment werden, er wird noch nicht betankt, aber ich glaube, er wird bedruckt. Also das findet jetzt statt. Er wird jetzt sozusagen für den Start vorbereitet. Ja, er wird ja zum Beispiel auch nicht vollgetankt verschickt. Also wir haben ja ein Micro Propulsion System, also so ein Antriebssystem, was ganz, ganz feine Impulse liefert.
Für die Lagerregelung.
Für die Lagerregelung. Wie gesagt, der Satellit darf ja nicht groß erschüttert werden. Und das wird mit Kaltgas gemacht. Also da wird nichts verbrannt, da wird einfach nur so ein bisschen Gas ausgestoßen. Das sind dann ganz, ganz feine Schübe. Und wenn ich jetzt richtig informiert bin, wird er zur Zeit bedruckt. Und danach kommt er dann zur Betankung.
Also bedruckt, es wird Gas hineingedrückt. Ja, ich dachte schon, jetzt vielleicht nochmal da.
Es ist auch eine Art von Betankung.
Eine neue Flagge aufgedruckt wird.
Ist auch eine Art von Betankung. Da werden wahrscheinlich nochmal Lektests auch durchgeführt, ob wirklich alles dicht ist an den Antriebssystemen. Und dann kommt er entsprechend zur Betankung.
Aber im Prinzip muss man jetzt wirklich die kompletten Transponder-Module nochmal durchtesten und schauen, verhält sich das in der Kommunikation?
Ja, nicht nur die Boxen, sondern die mussten danach, nachdem sie eingebaut worden sind, natürlich auch nochmal im Gesamtsystem des Satelliten getestet werden. Es hilft ja nichts, jetzt die Boxen alleine nochmal zu sagen, ok, das tut jetzt, sondern tut die Box auch wieder zusammen mit dem kompletten Satelliten. Das musste natürlich auch nochmal getestet werden. Und das alles in einer ganz, ganz kurzen Zeit.
Das heißt, da ist das Testcenter der ESA in Holland, in Nordwijk, ist da sozusagen richtig aktiv geworden. Weil die müssen ja im Prinzip auch die ganzen Referenzmessungen etc., also alle vorherigen Testergebnisse dann aus der Schublade holen und sicherstellen, dass es immer noch auf demselben Level ist.
Da arbeiten natürlich ganz viele Leute zusammen. Also da arbeitet jetzt natürlich nicht nur die ESA, sondern auch der Hersteller des Satelliten mit uns zusammen. Also das ist ein riesiger Aufwand von einem ganz großen Team. Also das machen ja natürlich nicht nur wir alleine.
Ja, aber wir hatten ja auch mal hier eine Sendung. Können wir mal wieder mal eine Sendung pluggen hier. Raumzeit 18, vom Testcenter eben, S-TEC, also die kompletten Facilities, wo eben dann üblicherweise ja die ganzen Raumfahrzeuge und so wird es ja mit Gaia dann auch gewesen sein, dort erst mal hinkommen, bevor sie verschifft werden und dort auf Herz und Nieren getestet werden, wo ja nicht nur getestet wird, ob das funktioniert, sondern wo ja auch im Rahmen dieser Tests überhaupt erst mal die ganzen Grunddaten generiert werden, die dann später vielleicht, wenn mal was schiefläuft, wo man dann sagen kann, ja, ihr habt das doch ausgemessen, was habt ihr denn da rausgefunden, ja, was weiß ich, um vielleicht später dann doch nochmal irgendwelche Anomalien festzustellen oder überhaupt auch Sachen erst mal ausschließen zu können. Und in dem Fall nehme ich mal an, wird da auch sehr viel verglichen worden sein, ob sozusagen immer noch derselbe Satellit da ist, den man auch meint, loszuschicken.
Ja gut, ich meine, in dem Fall war zum Glück der Eingriff, sag ich mal, jetzt nicht ganz so massiv, was jetzt den Satelliten angeht. Also er hat jetzt dadurch seine Eigenschaften, was jetzt Thermalstruktur angeht oder, ja elektrisch wahrscheinlich ein bisschen, aber eben nicht massiv, hat er zum Glück nicht verändert. Also was da natürlich sehr stark ausgetestet worden ist, ist die Kommunikation, ganz klar.
Ob die Protokolle noch greifen?
Ja, ob das alles mit den Frequenzen funktioniert und ob wir wirklich sicher sind, dass wir mit dem Satelliten kommunizieren können.
Na, das wär ja was gewesen. So, jetzt ist man sich also verhältnismäßig sicher, so sicher man sich sein kann und das Schwitzen geht los.
Ja, jetzt geht natürlich das Schwitzen los.
Im Prinzip deine erste richtige Mission, die du so von Anfang an, nicht ganz von Anfang an, aber sehr weit begleitet hast.
Na, das ist schon super spannend, würde ich sagen. Also ich fieber jetzt dem neuen Statum schon sehr entgegen. Es ist natürlich super spannend. Ja, es ist die erste Mission, die man so richtig gemacht hat. Man hat ausgerechnet, wann die Rakete abheben soll. Und ich glaube, dann ist man natürlich auf den Countdown extrem gespannt. Ja, klappt das alles, wird sie wirklich dann abheben oder geht in der letzten Minute dann doch noch irgendwo ein rotes Lämpchen an?
Wenn es nicht klappen würde, was wäre denn das nächste Fenster, müsste man dann wieder lange warten?
Das ist relativ interessant. Also das hängt von der Sojus ab. Sobald die Sojus betankt ist, hat man letztendlich drei Tage Zeit. Weil der Treibstoff ist sehr, sehr aggressiv und greift dann auch die Rakete an. Und wenn die nach drei Tagen nicht abgehoben ist, dann wird es sehr kritisch. Ich glaube, man hat noch eine vierte Chance. Aber danach wird nicht mehr gestartet. Und dann muss erst die Rakete sozusagen rund überholt werden. Dann hat man ein Problem. Aber solange die Rakete nicht getankt ist, hat man dann durchaus noch die Möglichkeit, den Start nach hinten zu verschieben. Also wir haben Startfenster, was sich jetzt, glaube ich, am 5. Januar schließt. Was natürlich nicht wünschenswert ist, weil wir hoffen natürlich nicht, dass man irgendwie über Weihnachten starten muss, sondern dass vor Weihnachten wirklich die kritischen Sachen vorbei sind. Weil wenn der Satellit am 19. startet, ist natürlich am 20. dann zum Beispiel dieses kritische Manöver, dass wir Gaia eben noch beschleunigen müssen, dass wir es wirklich bis zum Liebrationspunkt schaffen. Es muss natürlich alles geplant werden.
Damit die Weihnachtplanung nicht auch noch durcheinander gebracht wird. Ja Florian, haben wir noch irgendwas Wichtiges vergessen, was man noch erwähnen sollte?
Ich glaube, wir haben soweit alles abgedeckt. Was für Gaia interessant ist. Wahrscheinlich gibt es tausend Sachen, die noch interessant sind, aber...
Immer. Gibt es immer. Aber das war schon sehr viel Interessantes dabei. Vielen Dank für die Ausführungen zu Gaia. Ja, und das war es hier. Die 57. Ausgabe von Raumzeit. Ich hoffe, es hat euch gefallen. Wir sagen Tschüss und bis bald.